bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénna hier soir les
sénateurs ont définitivement adopté la
règle d'or prévue par l'article 3 du
traité budgétaire européen et qui oblige
la France à réduire son déficit
structurel à 0,5 % de son PIB le texte
crée notamment un Haut Conseil des
finances publ dont la composition était
très discutée au Sénat celui-ci exigeant
le respect de la parité hommes-femme les
sénateurs ont ensuite poursuivi avec
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
2013 tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle pour l'examen de ces deux
textes très bonne matinée à tous sur
Public
Sénat l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen
des conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargé d'élaborer un texte sur
les dispositions restant en discussion
du projet de loi organique relatif à la
programmation et à la gouvernance des
finances publiques dans la discussion
générale la parole est à notre collègue
François Marc rapporteur pour le Sénat
de la commission mixte paritaire vous
avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur
merciés madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues la commission
mixte paritaire s'est effectivement
réunie le jeudi 8 novembre
2012 et elle a établi le texte commun
qui vous est aujourd'hui proposé alors
la CMP a bien sûr confirmé l'économie
générale du texte qu'aucune des deux
assemblées n'avaient d'ailles remise en
cause et que je rappelle en quelques
mots la loi organique prévoit que les
lois de programmation des finances publi
devront fixer un objectif de solde
structurel à moyen terme et la
trajectoire année par année pour y
parvenir ce faisant nous transposons en
droit interne la règle qui figure à
l'article 3 du traité sur la stabilité
la coordination et la gouvernance qui
est d'ailleurs la même ou presque que
celle du volet di préventif du PACT de
stabilité pour assurer la cohérence
entre cette trajectoire et les lois
financières annuelles un article
liminaire figurera avant la première
partie des lois de
finances pour vérifier que nous
respectons bien la trajectoire nous
créons rappelez-vous le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques qui sera notre
conseil budgétaire indépendant en
quelque sorte selon la terminologie du
droit communautaire le Haut Conseil
donnera un des avis sur le cadrage
macro-économique des textes financiers
au moment de leur examen par le
Parlement et il analysera bien sûr aussi
les résultats de
l'exécution alors le Conseil
constitutionnel a annoncé dans sa
décision du 9 août 2012 sur le TSG qu'il
tiendrait compte des avis du Haut
Conseil lorsqu'il aura apprécié la
sincérité des lois financières
au-delà de la règle du TSCG la nouvelle
loi organique codifie le contenu de nos
actuelles lois de programmation des
finances publicque et du rapport qui
leur est
annexé je voudrais d'abord insister mes
chers collègues sur le fait que les
apports du Sénat au fonctionnement du
cœur du dispositif organique ont été
maintenus ainsi le gouvernement devra
comme le proposait la commission des
finances expliqué dans le rapport annexé
aux loi de programmation ses prévisions
sur la croissance mais aussi sur le
niveau des Produits Intérieurs brut
potentiel qui est la variable
essentielle pour calculer le sol
structurel afin d'encourager la
convergence des méthodes il devra
expliquer ses différences d'approche
avec la Commission
européenne le Haut Conseil pour sa part
devra explicitement se prononcer sur les
hypothèses de payb potentiel comme
l'avait également souhaité la commission
des finances du
Sénat il devra motiver ses avis et
lorsqu'il se prononcera sur les
hypothèses macro-économiques il devra
exprimer son avis en tenant compte du
consensus des conjoncturiste c'est ce
que nous avions
préconisé ainsi tout bien optimiste dans
les avis du Haut Conseil devra être
pleinement
assumé enfin à l'initiative de notre
collègue Jean-Pierre café et du groupe
socialiste les règles du jeu ont été
exprimées de manière claire et nous
avons éliminé le risque que le Haut
Conseil les finances publiques puisse en
faisant varier dans le temps ses
hypothèses de pb potentiel dicter au
Parlement le montant des mesures
d'ajustement à prendre chaque année ce
risque a été
écarté avec la rédaction que nous avons
retenu à l'article 16 le rôle du Haut
Conseil consistera clairement à
apprécier si oui ou non l'exécution au
titre d'une année donnée est conforme
aux engagements politiques pour cette
même
année les dispositions nous avions
introduit à l'article 15 pour assurer
l'indépendance du Haut Conseil ont été
maintenu et même complété par le
dispositif issu de la proposition du
président Marini et consistante à
prévoir pour le Haut Conseil un budget
propre inscrit à la mission conseil et
contrôle de
l'État les propositions visantes à
systématiser l'intervention du Haut
Conseil ont également moyennant quelques
ajustements rédactionnels été
conservé de la même façon nous avons
préservé l'essentiel des app de la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat en particulier les collectifs
sociaux devront comporter comme les
collectifs budgétaires un article
liminaire retraçant les leur incidence
sur la trajectoire du solde
structurel par ailleurs l'information du
Parlement sur les régimes sociaux hors
champ du PLFSS sera très utilement
accru grâce aux initiatives de nos
collègues Jean lecte et Jean
artui formation du Parlement sera
améliorée dans le domaine du horsban de
l'État et en particulier sur les
partenariats publics privés ainsi que
sur les beau administratifs
hitthéotiques ce sont sans doute les
premières pierres d'un chantier plus
ambitieux alors je dois aussi bien sûr
signaler que certains apports du Sénat
n'ont pas été retenus par la CMP c'est
la règle du genre ainsi le souhait de la
commission des finances de prévoir un
avis du Haut Conseil des finances public
sur l'ensemble des textes européens
ayant une incidence budgétaire qui avait
pour objet de rendre ces documents plus
visibles dans le débat politique
nationale n'a pas été
retenu alors je vais conclure mes chers
collègues par deux
sujets quoique assez éloigné de l'objet
essentiel de la loi organique mais qui
sont ceux auxquels la CMP a consacré le
plus de
temps en premier lieu je voudrais
évoquer les conditions de nomination des
membres du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques nous avions souhaité que les
membres nommés par la Cours des comptes
soit désigné après audition conjointe
par les commissions des finances et des
affaires sociales des deux
assemblées après avoir envisagé de
supprimer cette formalité nous l'avons
finalement étendu par souci de cohérence
aux membres nommés par le président du
Conseil économique social et
environnemental nous devrons donc mes
chers cèg procéder tous les 2 ans et
demi soit à 5
auditions les années où le membre nommé
par le CSE est renouvelé soit à quatre
auditions je voudrais conclure par un
aspect de la loi organique qui sera
peut-être amené à prospérer à savoir
l'obligation est dictée par une règle de
niveau organique de respecter
strictement la parité entre les femmes
et les hommes pour les nominations au
sein du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques sur
le sur le principe sur le principe cette
obligation qui avait été introduite au
Sénat à l'initiative du groupe
écologiste n'est pas totalement nouvelle
la loi organique de 19 juillet 2010
relative au Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature dispose déjà que les
nominations par différentes autorités je
cite concours dans chaque à une
représentation équilibrée des hommes et
des femmes fin de citation nous avons
pour le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques souhaitait aller plus loin et
assurer une parité totale au sein des
personnalités désignées les
personnalités désignées étant au nombre
de 9 sur les 11 que constituent qui cons
le Haut
Conseil puisque le dispositif adopté par
le Sénat présentait des difficultés
pratiques et que plusieurs sénateurs
notamment mariefance befice
avait souhaité que je puisse y
travailler avant la
CMP j'ai eu l'occasion de formuler une
proposition qui a été
retenue alors cette proposition stipule
que pour les membres issus de la Cour
des comptes la solution est simple
puisque tous les 30 mois le premier
président de la Cour des comptes doit en
renouveler
deux il faudra qu'il désigne à chaque
fois un homme et une femme c'est facile
pour les membres nommés par le Parlement
la question est plus compliquée car
chaque autorité de désignation ne
désigne qu'un seul membre puisque
rappelez-vous le président de chaque
assemblée désigne un membre et les
présidents des commissions des finances
désignent chacun d'entre eux un membre
il nous est apparu d'emblé nécessaire
d'exclure l'obligation pour ces
autorités de s'entendre entre
elles cela aurait limité leur pouvoir de
nomination et cela aurait comporté des
risques de blocage nous nous sommes donc
inspirés du dispositif déjà prévu pour
déterminer ceux des membres désignés en
2013 qui feront un mandat de 30 mois et
ceux qui pourront faire un mandat de 5
ans il s'agit du tirage au sort qui est
donc déjà prévu pour ce cas de figure et
nous avons suggéré qu'il puisse être
étendu ce dispositif de tirage au sort
pour justement les membres désignés par
le Parlement et donc un tirage au sort
désignera les deux autorités
parlementaires qui auront l'obligation
de désigner d'abord une femme et les
deux qui désigneront d'abord un homme à
l'expiration de ces mandats ces
autorités ou leurs successeurs devront
désigner une personnalité de l'autre
sexe et ainsi les équilibres seront
totalement
respecté alors le le président du CESE
se verra appliquer un régime de même
esprit un tirage au sort lui indiquera
s'il doit désigner en 2013 un homme ou
une femme puis il devra choisir en
alternance un homme ou une
femme voilà alors ce
dispositif qui peut ne pas apparaître
très simple Prim àord mais qui au fond
n'est pas compliqué à mettre en
œuvre ce dispositif assure qu'autant de
femmes que d'hommes seront dans la durée
dans la durée nommé au Haut Conseil des
finances publiques ce qui est l'objectif
premier de la parité nous sommes donc
mes chers collègues parvenus à une
solution innovante qui je l'espère fera
école dans d'autres organismes composés
de membres dont le mandat n'est pas
renouvelable ayant ainsi présenté la
teneur de cette proposition émanant de
la CMP et ayant souligné les apports du
Sénat et en particulier les avancées
obtenues s'agissant de ces points sur le
fonctionnement au conseil en particulier
le respect de la
parité je vous invite à adopter le texte
proposé par la Commission Mixte
Paritaire je vous remercie merci
monsieur le rapporteur
général la parole est à Monsieur le
Ministre Jérôme Cahusac ministre chargé
du
budget merci madame la Présidente le
texte issu de la commission mixte
paritaire abouti à un compromis auquel
le gouvernement donne son acccord en
effet ces travaux ont certes modifié le
chapitre 1er mais dans un sens qui
paraît tout à fait satisfaisant au
gouvernement qu'il s'agit de
l'obligation faite dans le rapport
annexé à la loi de programmation sur le
montant et la date d'échéance des
engagements financiers significatifs de
l'État pardon en cours et n'ayant pas
d'implication immédiate dans le sold
structurel on a eu ce débat le Sénat
s'en souvient à l'initiative notamment
de Jean artui
ou qu'il s'agisse de l'obligation
également issu des travaux du Sénat
d'intégrer dans les lois de financement
rectificative ou de sécurité
sociale d'un article retraçant
l'approche toute administration
publique approbation également dès lors
que le rapporteur général vient de
l'indiquer approbation donc sur le mode
de composition du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques le gouvernement ne
méconnaît pas les difficultés pratiques
auxquel euh euh les uns et les autres
vont devoir se confronter mais ne doute
pas que ces difficultés seront
surmontées euh avec euh en conséquence
un incontestable progrès en matière de
de parité là encore c'est à l'initiative
du Sénat que la chose fut faite et je
souhaitais le le signaler en m'exprimant
euh aujourd'hui enfin sur la procédure
régissant les interventions et sur son
statut budgétaire la CMP a choisi
d'imposer que l'avis euh du haut
comomité sur les prévisions macro
économiques soit rendu avant l'adoption
du projet de loi la CMP a également
préféré supprimer le projet d'article 13
bis qui imposait la consultation de ce
comité sur les projets de documents
adressés aux institutions européennes et
suivant une proposition de votre
président de la commission des finances
la CMP a finalement choisi d'écrire que
les crédits nécessaires au
fonctionnement de ce comité sont
regroupés au sein d'un programme
spécifique de la mission conseil et
contrôle de l'État il me semble que ça
me paraît être un bon compromis entre ce
qu' paraissait être la volonté du Sénat
et ce avait souhaité le gouvernement au
nom de celui-ci je veux vous dire donc
ma vraie satisfaction enfin la
disposition concernant l'information du
Parlement sur les formes d'endettement
caché de l'État également été retenu je
crois que c'est une bonne chose
l'article 17a j'ai déjà cité le sénateur
jeanartu je le fais à nouveau le
gouvernement appelle donc la la Haute
Assemblée à se prononcer favorablement
sur les conclusions de la commission
mixte paritaire une institution dont
tous les parlementaires connaissent la
l'importance et l'utilité une
institution qui très régulièrement
produit des conclusions que le
gouvernement est heureux d'approuver
devant vous mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs merci monsieur le
ministre dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est au président
Thierry
fouco madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mes chers collègues euh nous
voici donc au terme de la discussion sur
ce projet de loi organique relative à la
gouvernance et à la programmation des
finances publiques le projet de loi de
notre avis obéit comme nous l'avions
indiqué d'ailleurs en première lecture à
un principe fort simple il ne s'agit ni
plus ni moins que de traduire dans notre
droit budgétaire je dirais ce qu'il en
reste après l'adoption d'un pareil texte
les obligations appitables à la France
en vertu du traité budgétaire européen
dit traité sur la stabilité la
coordination et la gouvernance au sein
de l'Union économique et monétaire sans
aller plus loin dans la démonstration je
ne peux que je ne peux manquer de
souligner la cohérence de la position de
notre groupe parlementaire opposé au TSG
dès sa signature au mois de mars de
cette année par Nicolas Sarkozi au titre
de la France traité dont la ratification
à la virgule près a été réalisée avant
le vote de la présente loi organique et
qui naturellement ne peut que opposé à
la dite loi organique une loi organique
qui ressemble fortement à la règle d'or
budgétaire que Nicolas Sarkozi voulait
imposer il fut un temps et que combattit
alors l'ensemble de la gauche
parlementaire encore dans l'opposition
alors je ne sais s'il suffit d'un retour
aux affaires du pays pour que le
réalisme et le pragmatisme l'emporte à
chaque fois sur les convictions et les
principes mais forcé de constater que
l'on peut s'interroger sur la cohérence
je dirais absolue au plan politique de
certaines positions ce n'est pas hélas
parce que François Hollande est devenu
président de la République que le mode
de construction européenne qui déroule
sous nos yeux son long cortège de plans
d'austérité de recul des acquis sociaux
de mise en cause des avancées
démocratiques sociales économiques qui
ont été conquises par le pop rien je
dirais ne s'est inflchi l'Europe unie ce
beau ce grand projet qui devenu une zone
de paix nous diraient les jurés du Prix
Nobel mais ce serait oublié un peu vite
que la youoslavie s'est dchiré sous nos
yeux avec la bénédiction hélas de l'un
de nos principaux acteurs de la
construction européenne à savoir la
République fédérale allemande qui
attendait de la partition de cet état de
pouvoir faire de la Slovénie et de la
Croatie la même arrière-cour de son
économie comme elle l'a fait d'ailleurs
avec la la République tchèque la
Slovaquie la Hongrie ou alors la Pologne
l'Europe est certes la première zone
économique du monde mais elle connaît
bien plus que les autres le
développement ces dernières années de la
pauvreté pauvreté grandissante de sa
population la plus modeste et un très
sérieux ralentissement de l'activité
économique alors dans ce contexte plutôt
que de solidarité entre les États c'est
de concurrence mais aussi d'animosité
que se nourrit la construction
européenne entre une Grande-Bretagne par
exemple véritable passagers clandestin
abritant dans sa capitale le lieu la
City la City de Londres où se pratique
avec le plus de vigueur la spéculation
euh contre l'euro lui-même euh où l'ont
fait monter les enchères sur les dettes
souveraines
euh et des pays comme le Luxembourg par
exemple ou alors l'Autriche attaché au
secret bancaire qui a fait la fortune si
l'on peut dire de leur économie ou des
pays du Sud Grèce Portugal Espagne
saigné au 4 vein par les plans
d'austérité qui d'ailleurs leur sont
imposés alors les gouvernant gouvernants
européens ne semble pas avoir réussi
d'ailleurs à se mettre d'accord sur le
budget
communautaire c'est mal d'ailleurs parti
pour le PACT de croissance et tout se
déroule je dirais dans une sorte de
Sauve qui peeu générale où chacun essaie
de tirer les marrons du sans penser
forcément à ce que cela implique pour
les autres objet donc du 1è également
cure d'austérité la Grèce semble dans la
plus parfaite incapacité de faire face
aux engagements qu'on lui a fixé ce qui
a d'ailleurs une explication je dois
dire assez simple c'est qu'à vouloir
réduire coûte que coûte les salaires les
traitements pensions et retraite de la
population à ponctionner dans les
prestations sociales augmenter dans le
même temps la fiscalité indirecte sous
toutes ces formes on aboutit à la plus
évidente crise de débouché et récession
qu'on pouvait attendre de même la
flexibilisation accrue du marché du
travail assurer la progression du taux
de chômage plus sûrement que celle des
offres d'emploi disponible alors mes
chers collègues notons également
d'ailleurs qu'il faudrait bien qu'on
nous explique un jour en quoi la
facilité laissée aux entreprises pour
licencier du personnel peut constituer
à un moment donné un facteur de
croissance économique et de réduction
des déficits publics parce
qu'apparemment en Grèce en Espagne au
Portugal on s'est débauché sans limite
mais on a beaucoup plus de mal à
réembaucher ensuite c'est donc pour que
la France participe au mieux à cet
équipage je dirais bringballant de
l'Union européenne où la banque centrale
n'est même pas en situation de
refinancer les États souverains où elle
est n'est même pas dans capable de
respecter sa raison d'être celle
d'ailleurs de protéger la monnaie unique
que nous sommes aujourd'hui invités à
voter cette loi organique posons passons
sur la mise en place par le présent
texte du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques outre le fait qu'il est
évident que l'existence même de
l'organisme sera source de conflit entre
la représentation nationale et la
structure
quant au droits et devoirs des uns et
des autres il faut nous interroger sur
l'apport réel de la création du Haut
Conseil de ce point de vue comme l'a
écrit je ne sais quel journal économique
le Haut Conseil sera le chien de garde
de de l'orthodoxie budgétaire plus
encore qu'un outil d'évaluation
objective des politiques publiques
mettant donc la France en demord de
participer à une aventure politique pour
le moins inscrite dans une période
critique marqué par une vité tous aimut
qui contamine l'ensemble des politiques
publiques européennes le Tex place
ensuite notre pouvoir budgétaire sous le
regard d'une autorité indépendante qui
aura plutôt fait d'aller au-delà de ses
prérogatives excluant par la même tout
contrôle populaire et citoyen sur
l'utilisation de l'argent dans notre
pays il n'y a donc dans cette affaire
aucune avancée de la démocratie sociale
aucune avancée de nos libertés
fondamentales aucune prise en compte des
aspir des populations il n'y a qu'une
soumission sans cesse renforcée à la
seule loi des marchés financiers puisque
toutes les politiques budgétaires
devront conduire à la réduction des
déficits à celle des dettes publiques et
au règlement subséquent des intérêts
d'ailleurs et qui les grèv posons donc
la question quand donc la Banque
centrale européenne décidera-t-elle par
principe de consacrer un certain volume
de création monétaire annuel au
financement public des différents pays
de la zone euro imaginez mes chers
collègues j'en ai fini madame la
Présidente que la BCE prête tous les ans
50 milliards d'euros à 1% d'intérêt à la
France ce que nous pourrions par une
juste allocation faire avec et de quel
poids nous serions libéré vous
comprendrez donc aisément que pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons nous ne
puissions que confirmer notre position
de première lecture en parfaite
cohérence avec la position exprimée dès
le départ le texte de cette loi
organique créant la prétendue règle
budgétaire nous ne pouvons l'accepter
merci monsieur le Président fouco la
parole est à notre collègue François
Fortassin
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
budget monsieur le président de la
commission des
finances la commission mixte paritaire
mes chers collègues pardon commission
mixte paritaire chargée de proposer un
texte sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi organique
relative à la programmation à la
gouvernance des finances publiques est
parvenu un accord le 8 novembre dernier
voilà qui est une bonne nouvelle je
remarque que cette CMP a souvent retenu
la rédaction proposée par le Sénat
moyennement éventuellement quelques
modifications il faut dire que grâce
notamment à la
vigilance de notre rapporteur général le
Sénat a réalisé un excellent travail sur
ce texte et nous ne pouvons que l'en
féliciter en même temps que nous en
félicitons ce projet de loi organique
est relativement consensuel je pense que
personne ne compte teste la nécessité de
gérer les denniers publics de façon
responsable nous ne pouvons pas
continuer à faire peser sur nos enfants
et petits-enfants un endettement
déraisonnable que nous sommes incapables
de maîtriser certes il y a y compris au
sein de mon groupe le RDSE des positions
divergentes sur le texte puisqu'il
résulte du traité sur la stabilité la
coordination et la gouvernance au sein
de l'Union économique et monétaire le
TSCG qui a des chîner des passions dans
les deux assemblées pour ma part je
considère que ce texte est plutôt une
avancée tout d'abord parce qu'il
renforce la logique pluriannuelle de la
gestion des finances publiques et ainsi
la visibilité sur l'action du
gouvernement ce qui ne peut-être qu'une
bonne chose à la fois pour nos
concitoyens et pour nos
entreprises un point simplement me
chagrine légèrement dans ce projet de
loi organique c'est la création d'un
Haut Conseil des finances publique non
pas que je conteste la nécessité de
disposer
d'évaluations macroéc indépendantes de
des prévision macro-économique qui
soutendent les lois des finances je
pense que cela consuera un véritable
progrès et renforcera l'informations et
les prérogatives du Parlement cependant
je m'interroge sur le choix de créer
cette Haute Autorité supplémentaire
surtout en cette période de restriction
budgétaire en outre rien ne garantit que
ce au Conseil adossé à la cour des
compes est composé en partie de
magistrat
de de cette institution soit même de
réaliser de telles évaluations
véritablement
fiables cela étant dit je pense que la C
a bien fait de retenir les modifications
apportées par les amendements de notre
rapporteur général qui précise les
modalités de fonctionnement de ce au
conseil comme il vous l'a précisé il y a
quelques
minutes de même si le Corum pour ces
réunions a été réduit sur proposition de
l'Assemblée nationale l'article 15 bis
introduit par le président de notre
commission des finances et qui vise à
garantir l'autonomie budgétaire du Haut
Conseil a également été maintenue en CMP
en échange de quelques modification
enfin tout comme dans héicycle de long
débat on semble-t-il animer la CMP à
propos de la proposition de nos
collègues écologistes d'introduire la
parité au sein du conseil des finances
publiques gr aux propositions des deux
rapporteurs généraux de l'assemblée du
Sénat la CMP est parvenu à une rédaction
plus consensuelle de cet article qui
devrait garantir une bonne
applicabilité si les discussions se sont
beaucoup concentrées sur ce ha conseil
ce projet de loi organique oduit
également d'autres changements
importants notamment le pilotage
structurel des finances publiques
c'est-à-dire des règles plus pertinentes
économiquement et plus souple que celle
qui prévalent jusqu'ici ou qui Préval
aller jusqu'ici pardon par conséquent le
vote du RDSE sur ce texte sera conforme
à celui de la première lecture et à
celui du TSCG à savoir que la majorité
des membres du groupe votera en faveur
de ce projet de loi organique et trois
de nos collègues ne l'approuveront
pas merci merci chers
collègues la parole est à André
gatola
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le groupe
écologiste du Sénat a unanimement voté
en faveur de la loi qui nous occupe lors
de son premier passage devant notre
assemblée le groupe écologiste votera à
nouveau en sa faveur ce soir alors que
nous examinons les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire qui s'est
réuni à son propos le 8 novembre dernier
l'essentiel a déjà été dit lors de notre
précédente discussion et je serai donc
bref si les écologistes ont dès le
départ choisi d'appuyer cette loi
organique c'est parce qu'elle découle
d'une obligation légale suite à la
ratification du traité européen de
stabilité de coordination et de
gouvernance en matière économique c'est
aussi parce qu'en choisissant la voie
d'une loi organique plutôt que d'une
modification de la Constitution
le président de la République et le
gouvernement ont préservé la capacité
des pouvoirs publics et du législateur à
amender les dispositifs qu'elle met en
place si le besoin devait s'en faire
sentir à
l'avenir vous le savez les écologistes
ne sont pas en parfait accord avec
certains aspects de ce dispositifs la
gouvernance budgétaire nous semble ici
trop étroitement conçue trop étriqué le
retour très rapide à un déficit maximal
égal à 3 % du PIB nous semble brutal et
manqué un peu de réalisme nous avons
rappelé tout à l'heure alors que
débutait pardon la discussion relative
au projet de loi des finances pour
l'année 2013 certaines de nos
inquiétudes nous les avons aussi évoqué
lors du débat relatif à cette loi nous
avions déposé plusieurs amendements qui
visaient à préciser le rôle ou améliorer
le fonctionnement du Haut Conseil des
finances publicque que cette loi
institue certains étaient de nature très
technique et portaient par exemple
exemple sur les demandes d'explication
et de transparence sur les hypothèses
prises en compte par le Haut conseil aux
finances publiques dans la formulation
de ces avis d'autres étaient de nature
plus politique et Auxon mot
d'inspiration plus citoyenne j'ai en
tête la question de la composition du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques que
nous avons suggéré de rendre plus
paritaire 7 de nos amendements avaient
été adoptés au Sénat quatre les plus
importants à mon sens ont depuis été
confirmés par la commission mixte
paritaire dont celui sur la question de
la parité hommes-femme qui a pu lors de
la CMP être amélioré notamment en
l'élargissant à l'ensemble des membres
du Haut conseil je tiens à ce sujet à
remercier tout particulièrement Monsieur
le rapporteur général de la commission
des finances ma collègue Michel André et
tous les membres de la CMP qui ont
contribué à cette très grande avancée
rien ne nous garantit encore la qualité
des travaux de ce Haut Conseil seul
l'avenir pourra nous le dire mais il est
d'ors et déjà devenu un symbole au
niveau européen de l'instauration de la
parité hommees-femme dans le milieu de
la finance jusque-l terriblement rétif à
la présence de femmes dans ces organes
décisionnaires ou même simplement
consultatifs la portée politique de
cette loi n'en est évidemment que plus
grande je veux voir dans le ce processus
un signe très positif je veux voir dans
ce processus la preuve que nos chambres
parlementaires trop souvent et trop
longtemps considéré comme des chambres
d'enregistrement par les gouvernements
passés constituent bien plutôt des
chambres de réflexion d'innovation et
d'avancé déterminantes sur le plan
sociétal nous n'insisterons jamais assez
sur l'importance que rev pour nous et
pour le débat citoyen le respect que le
gouvernement accorde aux travaux du
Parlement et à la bonne intelligence que
les parlementaire doit mettre dans
l'amélioration des propositions
gouvernementales c'est le propre d'un
régime à la fois sain efficace et d'une
démocratie riche et cohérente avec
elle-même que d'agir comme le
gouvernement et le Parlement ont su agir
à propos de ce
texte madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je ne
résiste pas pour conclure à l'envie de
revenir une dernière fois sur la
dimension européen de ce texte pour
évoquer le Conseil européen qui s'ouvre
en ce moment même à
Bruxelles comme vous le savez sans doute
le Conseil européen doit examiner la
nomination éventuelle au sein du
directoire de la Banque centrale
européenne de Monsieur Yve merch
luxembourgeois dont la candidature a été
rejeté le 25 octobre dernier par le
Parlement européen lequel Parlement
européen n'a malheureusement en la
matière qu'un
avis qu'une voix consultative la raison
pour laquelle le Parlement européen a
rejeté cette candidature se trouve
précisément dans l'absence totale de
femmes au sein de ce directoire et plus
largement au sein des instances
des institutions économiques et
financières européennes une absence qui
scandalise d'ailleurs bien au-delà du
Parlement européen puisqueque près de
250 parlementaires nationaux italiens
allemands espagnol ou français dont 55
parlementaires français issus de tous
les groupes de cette assemblée ont
adressé ces derniers jours un appel au
président Van ronpoy pour l'alerter de
cette situation j'ai moi-même écrit
aujourd'hui avec Catherine taska au
président de la République pour que la
France AG en conséquence soit en
refusant la candidature de Monsieur
merch soit en promouvant la la
nomination d'une femme à la tête de du
futur office de supervisation bancaire
européenne mes chers collègues les
multiples plafonds de verr qui
continuent de contraindre nos sociétés
et empêch la parité homm-femme d'être
effective dans tous les grands champs de
la vie publique doivent tomber c'est
notre devoir démocratique de de toutes
les opportunités qui se présentent à
nous pour uvrer dans ce sens nous avons
su le faire avec cette loi en France
l'Europe doit savoir le faire dès à
présent lors de la tenue de l'actuel
Conseil européen je vous
remercie merci chers
collègue la parole est à Marie-Hélène
desg
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mon
intervention sera succinte le projet de
loi organique que nous nous apprêtons à
voter dans une très large majorité des
deux côtés de cet hémicycle et la
conséquence de la ratification par notre
Parlement le 22 octobre dernier du
traité sur la stabilité la coordination
et la gouvernance au sein de l'Union
économique et monétaire je rappelle que
ce traité avait été négocié par Nicolas
Sarkozi et qu'il a été adopté dans les
mêmes termes le groupe UMP se félicite
que ce projet de loi organique comme le
projet de loi de ratification fasse
l'objet d'un très large consensus il
transpose dans notre droit interne
notamment l'article 3 du TSCG qui
définit les conditions du retour
progressif à l'équilibre budgétaire avec
un objectif d'équilibre fixé à 0,5 % de
déficit structurel et des mécanismes de
correction en cas d'écart constatés nous
acceptons ces contraintes car nous
n'avons plus le choix trop de
gouvernements de droite comme de gauche
se sont affranchis des anciennes règles
du pacte de stabilité désormais
l'encadrement est plus strict c'est une
dynamique plus vertuuse la commission
mixte paritaire a confirmé des avancées
comme les moyens de failit le calcul du
du solde structurel à partir du solde
effectif le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques devra jouer un rôle important
l'intégration du directeur général de
l'INC entérriné par la CMP devrait être
un plus les engagements horsban de plus
en plus importants comme les
partenariats publics privés les
garanties d'emprunt les bon
anfithéotique seront mieux prises en
compte dans le cadre des lois de
programmation pluriannuelle leur suivi
sera ajouté à chaque loi de finances en
revanche la question de la parité au
sein du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques a abouti à un chilebl pour le
moins assez complexe un tirage au sort
sera organisé entre les présidents de
l'Assemblée nationale du Sénat des
commissions des finances et de chambres
pour savoir qui d'entre eux désignorant
en premier l'homme ou la femme d'une
manière plus générale ce qui est en jeu
avec ce texte que nous allons adopter
définitivement c'est la parole de la
France en Europe c'est sa crédibilité
sur les marchés financiers
internationaux dont nous aurons besoin
tant que nous devrons emprunter pour
couvrir nos déficits et c'est bien sûr
la possibilité pour notre pays de sortir
d'une crise qui fabrique des chômeurs et
rogne le pouvoir d'achat avec ce traité
la taxe sur les transactions financières
initié par Nicolas Sarkozi et qui va
bientôt se concrétiser avec plusieurs
partenaires européens et enfin l'Union
bancaire sur laquelle nous travaillons
de concert à la commission des finances
du Sénat notamment voici les sujets qui
nous rassemblent autour du projet
européen d'harmonisation fiscale et de
réorientation de l'économie européenne
qui nous mènera peut-être vers une union
monétaire budgétaire et fiscale qui nous
rendra tous plus fort pour traverser les
crises de ce monde en attendant et bien
le groupe P votera ce texte important
tel qu'il ressort des travaux de la
commission mixte paritaire je vous
remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à Jean y
Lecomte madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues le projet de loi relatif à la
programmation et la gouvernance des
finances publiques témoigne que l'on
peut respecter nos engagements européens
dans la parfaite souveraineté du
Parlement puisqu'il tire son origine
dans la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel du 9 août dernier qui
considérait que la règle d'équilibre des
finances publiques ne ne nécessitait pas
de modification constitutionnelle si
celle-ci est assurée par des
dispositions dont le plein respect et la
Stricte Observance tout au long des
procédures budgétaires sont garantis de
quelqu autre
façon sans revenir sur les principales
dispositions de cette loi sur de cette
loi organique qui a été très largement
commentée ici je salue le travail de la
commission mixte paritaire dont les
conclusions ont largement permis la
prise en compte du travail parlementaire
et singulièrement celui du
Sénat je veux revenir ici sur deux
points essentiel d'abord la parité
parité qui avait quelque peu échauffé
nos échanges il y a quelques semaines le
vote du Sénat a permis à notre
rapporteur général François Marc de
faire une proposition qui a été retenue
par la CMP elle prévoit que la
composition du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques sera paritaire l'exigence de
parité entre hommes et femmes
s'appliquera à l'ensemble des
nominations y compris à celle en
provenance de la Cour des comptes ce qui
va au-delà de notre vote de fin octobre
pour les autorités de nomination autre
que la Cour des comptes un mécanisme de
tirage au sort permettra d'indiquer
laquelle doit désigner un homme et
laquelle doit désigner une femme ces
autorités n'ont n'auront donc pas ass s
entendre entre elles comme le prévoyait
notre texte initial cela aurait pu
engendrer quelques blocages en changeant
il y a quelques années la Constitution à
l'initiative du Premier ministre Lionel
Jospin nous marquions notre souhait de
marquer une rupture avec les années où
les femmes avaient un statut d'exception
et d'alibi en politique pour établir une
parité dans les fêtes en changeant les
règles du jeu et en établissant des
règles strictes pour marquer un objectif
fort nous marquons une volonté un chemin
le gouvernement paritaire de Jean-Marc
Ho est aujourd'hui une marque et
témoigne une marque du chemin parcouru
et témoigne de cette résolution ce
combat qui se poursuit aujourd'hui dans
le monde politique doit aussi être
poursuivi dans le monde économique que
dire du bord de la Banque centrale
européenne ou des décisions ou des
directions ou des directions des
entreprises du 440 sinon qu'une
révolution des comportements est
aujourd'hui indispensable c'est l'esprit
de la résolution que nous marquons
aujourd'hui en établissant une
composition paritaire du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques à la frontière du
monde politique et du monde économique
un Haut Conseil des finances publiques
paritaires c'est à la fois un beau
symbole de la société que nous voulons
et une meilleure garantie d'une
représentation correcte de toutes les
compétences de notre pays dans cette
instance
ensuite second apport les engagements
hors bilan de
l'état trois amendements avaient été
adoptés par le Sénat sur proposition du
président Jean artui et de moi-même la
CMP valide l'obligation d'information
sur les engagements hors bilan de l'état
montant et date d'échéance dans le cadre
de ces lois des lois de programmation
pluriannuel et dans le projet de loi de
finances de l'année ainsi que sur sur
proposition du rapporteur de l'Assemblée
nationale l'inscription dans le compte
général de l'État joint au projet de
règlement la liste des contrats de
partenariat et des bots anfitotique
ainsi que leur montant et leur date d'ch
d'échéance cette proposition du
rapporteur avait vocation à répondre à
la préoccupation du exprimé par le
sénateur Jean artui lors de la
discussion de la loi organique et qui
souhaitait que le Parlement se prononce
a priori sur les montants d'engagement
possible de l'État dans les contrats de
partenariat et des beau anfitéotiques
cette préoccupation a à ce stade été
considéré comme trop difficile à mettre
en œuvre et c'est la raison de cette
proposition il convient de saluer cette
démarche de transparente sur les compte
de de transparence sur les comptes de
l'État le recours trop nombreux ces
dernières années à ce type de
financement allant bien au-delà de 1 %
du PIB rien que sur le budget du
ministère de la Justice engage à long
terme l'état ce dédire de ces
partenariats coûte souvent très cher et
les loyers perçus par les opérateurs
pendant des dizaines d'années axfixie
progressivement les budgets de certaines
missions de l'État il fallait mettre un
terme à cette dérive observée ces
dernières années avec une exigence de
transparence sur l'ensemble des
engagements financiers de l'État comme
les crédits d'impôt aujourd'hui
d'actualité ou les garanties de l'État
qui devront figurer dans les
informations financières données par le
gouvernement à la représentation
nationale sans s'imposer cette rigueur
et cette transparence afficher une
perspective d'équilibre serait
totalement factice car les données
publié ne donneraiit pas une idée
correcte de la poursuite de la de notre
de la la trajectoire de notre solde
structurel c'est la raison pour laquelle
je salue l'acceptation par le
gouvernement de cette discipline qui
renforcera la crédibilité de notre
signature c'est avec ce type de démarche
en donnant confiance aux opérateurs
économiques que nous pourrons retrouver
la voie de la croissance et de l'emploi
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général saluant les apports
significatifs de la CMP la qualité d'un
travail structurant entre les deux
chambres du Parlement et les apports de
cette loi organique le groupe socialiste
votera les conclusions de cette
commission mixte paritaire merci chers
collègues
monsieur le Président
Marini madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en quelques
mots je voudrais me réjouir à mon tour
de cet heureux travail en
commun du fait que nos débats ont
permis de renforcer d'améliorer très
significativement le texte du fait que
la commission mixte paritaire a é
fructueuse comme chacun des groupes l'a
souligné
eu cette loi organique est bien notre
outil de travail commun nous l'avons
forgé ensemble c'est une sorte de de
coproduction et je voudrais souligner
que de telles situations sont assez
rares dans nos hémicycles et et dans
notre vie parlementaire alors ne ne
boudons pas notre plaisir de l'avoir
fait et bien sûr je souhaite vivement
que les conclusions de la CMP soient
adoptées aussi largement que ne l'a été
le texte lors de son de la fin de son
examen par le Sénat avec une majorité
tout à fait
exceptionnelle si ma mémoire est bonne
de 320 voix c'est c'est c'est c'est une
configuration que l'on ne retrouvera
probablement pas très souvent merci mes
chers collègues de votre
attention merci monsieur le président
à ce stade la discussion générale et
Claus je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 42 aléa 12 du règlement le
Sénat examinant après l'Assemblée
nationale le texte élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire il se
prononce par un seul vote sur l'ensemble
du texte en ne retenant que les
amendements présentés ou acceptés par le
gouvernement je ne suis saisie d'aucun
amendement conformément à l'article 42
aléa 12 du règlement je vais mettre au
voix l'ensemble du projet de loi
organique relatif à la programmation et
à la gouvernance des finances publiques
dans la rédaction résultant du texte
élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de voix monsieur Yv dodini
vous avez la parole chers
collègues merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
quelques mots pour exp mon vote en ma
qualité de rapporteur général de la
commission des affaires sociales vous le
savez notre commission s'était saisie
pour avis sur le projet de loi organique
je voudrais me féliciter que la
commission mixte paritaire a repris la
quasi-ttalité des amendements adoptés au
Sénat à mon initiative et je voudrais en
remercier le rapporteur général de la
commission des finances qui a bien voulu
défendre ses amendements en CMP ceci
témoigne de l'excellent climat de
coopération qui règne entre nos deux
commissions
ce faisant nous avons s'agissant des
finances sociales des dispositions
organiques qui garantissent davantage la
crédibilité des lois de programmation
ces lois nous présenteront désormais une
estimation pluriannuelle des dépenses
d'assurance et des dépensesallocation
familiale nous aurons aussi une vision
claire des perspectives de recettes de
dépenses et de soldes des régimes
complémentaires de retraite et de
l'Unedic dans l'hypothèse du dépôt d'un
projet de loi rectificative de
financement de la sécurité sociale
figurera un article liminaire présentant
un tableau de situation de nos finances
publiques identique à celui prévu pour
les projets de loi de finance initial et
rectificative la représentation
nationale se trouvera ainsi parfaitement
informée avant l'examen des disposition
d'un collectif social enfin je me
réjouis que nous ayons trouvé une
solution pour que la commission des
affaires sociales soit associé au choix
des membres du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques cette solution cert n'est
peut-être pas parfaite faite mais elle
est raisonnable elle nous permettra de
travailler en bonne intelligence avec la
commission des finances pour vérifier la
compéten et l'impartialité des
nominations qui nous seront proposées
par avis le texte du Gouvernement était
bon le débat parlementaire l'a enrichi
la commission des affaires sociales y a
pris sa part je voterai bien entendu ce
projet de loi organique avec conviction
merci Monsieur
do en appliation
de l'article 59 du règlement le scrutin
public est de droit il va donc être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront au secrétaire un bulletin
blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
un bulletin bleu ceux qui souhaitent
s'abstenir un bulletin rouge le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques
instants non non non non
non
merci le scrutin est
ouvert
ne demande à
voter le scrutin est clos j'invite les
secrétaires à procéder au dépouillement
du
scrutin
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
résultat du scrutin numéro 37 sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi organique
relative à la programmation et la
gouvernance des finances publiques
nombre de votants
343 nombre de suffrages exprimés
342 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés 172 pour l'adoption 320 contre
22 le Sénat a
adopté monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous reprenons la discussion
du projet de loi de finances pour 2013
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Michel
bon
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues le projet de budget 2013 de
l'État est résolument en faveur de la
croissance de la compétitivité et de
l'innovation c'est un budget au cœur du
redressement productif
à cet égard l'élargissement du crédit
d'impôt recherche à certaines dépenses
d'innovation des
PME que propose le projet de loi de
finances est une mesure tout à fait
opportune c'était un engagement du
Président de la République c'est une
recommandation du rapport Gallois
j'avais moi-même évoqué cette question
dans mon rapport d'information sur le
crédit d'impôt recherche en juillet
dernier
il est nécessaire en effet de renforcer
la compétitivité des PME innovantes
parce qu'elles sont plus fragiles que
les grandes entreprises et disposent de
moyens financiers
moindres et puis notre retard sur
l'Allemagne doit être comblé au plus
vite alors que l'Allemagne est au 4e
rang des pays innovants de l'Union
européenne la France n'est qu'au 11e
rang 54 % des PME allemand demande ont
mis en place une innovation de produits
ou de procédés contre moins d'un tiers
des PME française or il y a
manifestement un continuum entre
recherche développement et innovation et
en France le maillon faible c'est
l'innovation il est donc logique
d'étendre le crédit d'impôt recherche
aux dépenses d'innovation mais la
frontière entre recherche et innovation
peut se révéler parfois
délicate aussi le projet de finance le
projet de loi de finance limite-t-il à
juste titre le crédit d'impôt recherche
innovation à certaines dépenses en aval
de la recherche et du développement
portant sur les activités de conception
de prototype de nouveaux produits ainsi
que sur les installations pilotes et le
taux appliqué à ces dépenses
d'innovation serait de 20 % soit un taux
inférieur à celui du crédit d'impôt
recherche qui est de 30 % cette
différenciation de taux peut se
concevoir dans la mesure où les dépenses
d'innovation sont plus proches du
marché les dépenses de recherche étant
plus éloigné et donc ici assurément et
plus rapidement rentable il ne faudrait
pas toutefois que cette différenciation
de taux soit source d'insécurité fiscale
pour les entreprises bénéficiaire du
crédit d'impôt recherche innovation
aussi l'administration fiscale
devra-t-elle recevoir des instructions
strictes pour qu'elle ne soit pas tenté
de rattacher trop facilement les
dépenses de recherche et développement
au crédit d'impôt recherche innovation
et non au crédit d'impôt recherche
strict auinsus parce que le premier est
moins coûteux que le second pour l'État
dans le même ordre d'idée je voudrais
revenir sur l'une des préoccupations
des entreprises est l'une des
préconisations de mon rapport
d'information les entreprises contrôlées
doivent être sécurisés par des garanties
qui aujourd'hui n'existent pas les
entreprises bénéficiaires du crédit
d'impôt recherche sont soumises à une un
double contrôle une vérification de
l'administration fiscale et une
expertise scientifique du ministère de
la recherche mais sans débat
contradictoire il conviendrait qu'un
décret instore ce débat contradictoire
et même que les entreprises puissent
demander une contre-expertise en cas de
désaccord donc la mesure du crédit
d'impôt recherche innovation est
opportune mais son mode de financement
proposé par le projet de loi de finances
me paraît ni juste ni efficace cette
mesure nouvelle qui coûte 300 million
d'euros et partiellement financé à
hauteur de 100 millions d'euros par la
suppression des taux majorés du crédit
d'impôt recherche ces taux de 40 et 35 %
bénéficie aux entreprises les deux
premières années de leur entrée dans le
dispositif fiscal or
l'IGF a démontré que les taux majorés
bénéficie à 90 % aux PME les PME
innovantes les start-up ont besoin de
trésorerie d'êide financière dès la
conception de leur produits innovants
d'autant plus que les banques françaises
leur font souvent défaut ces taux
majorés doivent être perçus moins comme
des taux incitatifs que comme des aides
financière leur suppression serait donc
dommageable aux PME notamment aux
nouvelles PME et puis il serait
paradoxal voire contradictoire de faire
financer une mesure bénéficiant aux PME
par une mesure d'économie supporté par
ces mêmes PME il n'est jamais bon de
reprendre d'une main ce que l'on a donné
de l'autre un autre mode de financement
me paraît souhaitable il serait par
exemple tout à fait possible de
remplacer la suppression des taux
majorés par une légère réduction de la
prise en compte des dépenses de
fonctionnement dans le calcul de
l'assiette du crédit d'impôt recherche
cette réduction s'appliquerait à toutes
les entreprises et non pas au seuls PME
ainsi les dépenses de fonctionnement
évalué je le rappelle forfaitairement ne
ser plus égal à 50 % des dépenses de
personnel et 75 % des amortissements
mais à 50 % dans les deux cas l'économie
réalisée serait précisément égale voire
supérieur aux 100 millions d'euros que
rapporterait la suppression des taux
bonifiés cette proposition est donc
indolor pour le budget de l'État et
quasi indolor pour les entreprises dès
l'instant où c'est la totalité d'entre
elles et non les seules p
qui serait concerné la stabilité
juridique du crédit d'impôtrecherche
demandé par les entreprises comme par le
rapport Galois serait tout à fait ainsi
respecté je souhaite monsieur le
ministre que le gouvernement puisse être
attentif à ces remarques et à cette
proposition constructive au service des
PME et de
l'innovation merci chers
collègues la parole est à Francis de
lâre
pour ça qu'il faut une leure
extérieure madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers
collègues rien n'est plus urgent que de
porter remède à une grave insuffisance
structurelle si on veut pas être
condamné faillite après faillite a géré
dans la douleur de multiples
disparitions
d'entreprises face à cette
urgence le gouvernement a choisi de ne
pas se
presser cette lenteur est une faute et
cette déclaration est signée de monsieur
jean-perevad qui fut vous le savez bien
directeur de cabinet de Monsieur morroi
Premier ministre en réalité dans ce PF
concernant la recherche du d'une réforme
structurelle qui pourrait concerner le
périmètre de l'État que vous appelez
désormais stratège on attendra donc
2014 car la situation va pas -il
s'améliorer selon le président de la
républ qui reçoit certes des messages
mais qui ne nous parviennent
pas nous partageons l'objectif de
réduire le déficit à 3 % du PIB pour
2013 mais déjà le PLF
repose sur une hypothèse de croissance
de 08 % qui est déjà contestée par une
majorité d'économistes et de bon sens en
réalité si on obser bien les
déclarations vous semblez parier sur une
sortie de crise de la zone euro au 2e
semestre 2013 et Monsieur Holland est
confiant et il énumère les si si la zone
euro sort de la crise si l'économie am
rebondit si la Chine retrouve une
croissance à deux chiffres si les prix
de l'énergie ne sont pas trop élevés et
même éventuellement si le SPD gagne les
élections en Allemagne en réalité 08 %
de croissance alors que l'on prlève 1,5
% de PIB manque en réalité de sérieux la
zone euro connaît toujours une crise
financière sans précédent grave et
encore
imprévisible monsieur le ministre vous
avancez des prédictions mais pas de
prévision étayé sérieusement l'Allemagne
elle-même vient de réviser en forte
baisse ses prévisions de croissance et
au surplus et c'est là où ça devient
grave les autres pays de la zone euro
n'attendent pas d'éclaircis miracles
pour faire des réformes structurelles
fortes aujourd'hui ce sont l'Italie et
l'Espagne qui en Europe nous prennent
des parts de marché et nous attendons
nous 2014 pour engagé la première marche
devant nous conduire vers une meilleure
compétitivité de nos entreprises et en
2013 nous allons par contre emprunter si
j'en crois le rapporteur général 171
milliards pour le budget de l'État une
quarantaine de milliards supplémentaires
probablement pour la cadèe et
probablement quelques autres milliards
pour les établissement ou organismes
périphériques géré par l'agence alors
j'ai une question très précise monsieur
le ministre est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner un chiffre sur l'endettement
supplémentaire prévisible du pays pour
fin 2013 on y incluant les
amortissements et le coût supplémentaire
en intérêt car même à 2 1 % sur 10 ans
la charge risque d'être rapidement
insupportable les marchés que l'on
critique souvent mais qui savent lire et
compter viennent d'ailleurs de
sanctionner en réalité votre propension
à la dépense vos IR réformer le marché
du travail et vos incohérences à
commander un rapport sur la
compétitivité de notre économie pour
indiquer avant même sa publication qu'il
n'engageait que son auteur et ce rapport
préconisait un élagement massif des
charges pesant sur les entrepreneurs
auquels vous infligez dans le budget qui
nous préoccupe aujourd'hui 10 milliards
de prélèvements fiscaux supplémentaires
en réalité le plan Galois est déjà
enterré par ce projet de loi de
finances et pour s'en
convaincre et pour s'en convaincre il
suffit de lire les déclarations de vote
des membres influents de votre majorité
composite et même de notre et de et même
de certains membres du
gouvernement il s'agit essentiellement
d'un écran de fumée qui a permis de
faire quelques au télévision mais en
tout cas il n'a pas convaincu les
marchés ni les entrepreneurs de notre
pays nous savons bien nous savons bien
chers collègues que l'objectif d'un
déficit de 3 % pour l'année 2013 est une
marche difficile à atteindre et
essentielle mais plutôt que d'amuser la
galerie en détricotant depuis des mois
les réformes de votre de vos
prédécesseurs vous auriez pu dialoguer
avec votre opposition ainsi que l'on
fait la plupart des gouvernements
européens pour tenter de suivre le bon
sens celui indiqué notamment par la Cour
des comptes qui préconisait un rapport
de moitié moitié entre la hausse des
impôts et la baisse des dépenses
publiques plutôt que 2/ers un/ers ainsi
pour 2013 les prélèvements
supplémentaires s'élèveront à 33 4
milliards d'euros alors que les dépenses
publiques devront baisser devrai baisser
de 10 milliards
par le gel en valeur sans que l'on
connaisse en réalité le détail hormis
quelques ajustements d'effectif par
département ministériel en réalité vous
sur ce budget vous disposez quelques
rustines quelques comptbl vous continuez
de protéger l'état redistributeur qui
flatte le consommateur et pénalise le
producteurs et vos innovations fiscales
l'illustrent
parfaitement il est donc difficile
d'appréhender la réalité la cohérence
d'une politique qui se voudrait nouvelle
en présence en réalité d'un budget
essentiellement de reconduction qu'on
appelait il y a pas encore si longtemps
de service votter et même l'examen plus
détaillé des missions nous apprend par
exemple monsieur le rapporteur de la
recherche du budget la recherche que ce
qui semblait être une priorité parmi les
priorités le budget recherche augmente à
peine d'un % c'est vous qui l'écrivez
dans votre rapport soit 361 million
d'euros et dans le même temps on inscrit
532 millions d'euros pour recaser les
services de Madame Dufflot dans le
Triangle d'Or à la
défense cet élu régional de l'Est
parisien aurait pu trouver des locaux
mes chers collègues trois fois moins
chers pasar chez elle dans le Val de
Marne elle aurait pu contribuer à
rééquilibrer l'Est ou la région
parisienne par rapport à l'ouest mais en
réalité nous sommes en présence d'une
GAB j d'une Gabe j au prix au prix que
des négociations qui sont engagés et
d'une nomenclatura qui ne se plaît que
dans l'Ouest parisien et qui sont les
deux marqueurs d'une décision aussi
abérrante quiillustre l'écart entre
votre discours sur la rigueur et les et
les réalités de votre budget je cite cet
exemple parce qu'en 10 minutes le temps
est court mais on pourra en citer bien
d'autres par contre vos innovations
fiscales sont beaucoup plus éclairantes
on peut même croire on peut même dire
monsieur le ministre que vous y metit
une vraie créativité d'abord une
création d'une tranche d'imposition
supplémentaire au taux de 45 % pour les
revenus supérieur et surtout la
contribution exceptionnelle de
solidarité de 75 % sur les revenus
d'activité professionnelle supérieure à
1 million cette deuxè mesure purement
idéologique
réjouit le monde entier d'un rapport
fiscal
ridicule ce chapeau de votre politique
fiscale donne de la France une image
désastreuse et ne peut que détourner les
potentiels investisseurs
stigmatise les créateurs d'entreprise et
d'emploi est une bonne stratégie alors
que la rction nous gu et que le chmage
saccroit en réalité elle encourage
monsieur le rapporteurévasion fiscal et
les entrepreneurs à quitté la France
c'est une réalité de nombreux pays à
l'image du Royaume-Uni leors découle le
tapis rouge même votre collègue le maire
de Londres qualifie la politique fiscale
de notre pays de pire tyrannie depuis
1789 il se dit
prêt il se dit prêt à accueillir tous
les Français talentueux à Londres le
message a été entendu et c'est bien ça
le pire puisque de puisque le nombre
exilés augmente les avocats fiscalistes
sont débordés la nouveauté la nouveauté
c'est que cela ne touche pas seulement
les prétendus riches de très nombreux
jeunes actuellement sans fortune mais
talentueux qui savent être engagés dans
des activités qui feront demain leur
succès et qui n'ont pas l'intention de
devenir les pigeons ils quittent le
territoire
massivement le gouvernement sanctionne
donc tous ceux qui pourrai créer des
emplois c'est un nouvel et dit de Dante
c'estclamé un avocat fiscaliste tout
cela va donc à l'encontre de ce que vous
affirmez il n'y a pas de signe d'un
quelconque exaude fiscal aussi monsieur
le ministre je vous invite à l'instar du
président de la commission des finances
de l'Assemblée nationale de nous
indiquer le nombre de Foyet fiscaux qui
sont en train de partir ou parti les
négociations de et le montant de l'exit
taxe qu'ils doivent normalement
percevoir avant leur déménagement fiscal
là-dessus c'est le grand flou je pense
que dans une discussion comme celle-ci
un de précision devrait devoir nous être
apporté contrairement aussi à votre
discours récurrent sur la justice ces
mesures fiscales impactent les classes
moyennes et les famille d'abord le
plafonnement général des effets du
conscient familial ensuite les emplois
familiaux qui sont découragés en
réduisant la déduction fiscale et enfin
moment de vérité la rétraction fiscale
sur les heures supplémentaires inscrites
sur leur dernière fiche de paye pour 9
millions de salariés viennent de prendre
mes chers collèises qu'ils sont les
nouveaux riches du pays ils vous en
seront probablement très reconnaissants
s'agissant des mesures fiscales touchant
directement les entreprises elles sont
nombreuses on peut même dire qu'elles
sont fouillées mais es sont souvent
malincontreuses la plusvalue sur cession
de titre de participation certains
fiscalist j cette mesure facilement
contournable car les sessions pourrai se
faire et pourront se faire à l'étranger
ce qui privera notamment l'état de
recette escompté l'aménagement alors là
de la déductibilité des charges
financières les intérêts d'emprunt
aujourd'hui les intérêts d'emprunt sont
totalement déductibles de l'impôt sur
les sociétés en 2013 il est proposé de
les réduire à hauteur de 85 % et de 75 %
à
2014 c'est c'est si je n'étais point
interrompu madame la Présidente j'aurais
aucun
problème synthétiser le barê progressif
a été mis en place sur les revenus du
capital à l'image de celui du travail
c'est un beau slogan de gauche mais là
INEX dans la réité car il s'agit souvent
pour le capital d'une double peine taxer
les
flux taxer les flux et les stocks
permets-toi de vous dire que c'est le
meilleur encouragement on peut même dire
que c'est l'encouragement du top du top
pour les délocalisation il en est de
même pour les gains net des sessions de
valeur immobilière et des droits sociaux
des particuliers en
réalité l'ensemble du dispositif
fiscal reflète une stratégie uniquement
de fuite en avant essentiellement
fiscale elle porte atteinte et c'est
peut-être cela le plus grave surtout
atteinte à la valeur travail
fondamentale dans notre société car
c'est à travers le travail que l'homme
crée des richesse susceptible d'être
redistribué cette simple idée de bon
sens ement contesté d'ailleurs encore ce
soir dans cette discussion
budgetaire animé par un certain nombre
de souousbressau d'un esprit 68ard dont
chacun sait qu'il n'a aucun avenir mais
dont l'agonie semble malheureusement
plus longue que
prévu merci chers
collègues la parole la parole est à
edmv
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre vous nous avez
présenté la stratégie budgétaire qui est
la vôtre elle est la nôtre il faut
qu'elle réussisse elle doit réussir
parce que c'est une stratégie juste qui
sert
l'équilibre
le
redressement le développement et la
croissance et dans cet objectif
stratégique les collectivités
territoriales ont toutes leur place au
cours de ces années certaines critiques
ont été faites à l'égard de ces
collectivités mais on a oublié leur rôle
essentiel que l'État savait d'ailleurs
retrouver lorsqu'il avançait des plans
de relance
des investissements d'avenir ou autres
programme
campus nos collectivités territoriales
représente en effet un potentiel
économique
déterminant au cours de ces 20 dernières
années leur place dans le produit
intérieur brut a été multiplié par de
elles sont
saines leur capacité de
remboursement observation du dernier
rapport de la cour des compte aux
alentours de 4 ans jamais leur
autofinancement n'avait été aussi
élevé et lorsque on observe les faits
monsieur le ministre il ne peut pas y
avoir une politique du logement du
transport des réseaux de
l'environnement des débits et autres
sans la participation profonde et
durable de ces collectivités à juste
titre vous parlez nous parlons de la
compétitivité des entreprises mais que
serait cette compétitivité s'il n'y
avait pas les service des collectivités
territoriales que ceci intéresse les
services publics traditionnels de
conseil ou l'aménagement et c'est donc à
très juste titre que monsieur le
Président de la
République a parlé d'un Pact de
confiance et de solidarité le 6 novembre
dernier Monsieur le Premier Ministre
également rappeler
et le rapport Gallois se fonde sur cette
prospective de confiance et lorsque nous
évoquons cette solidarité entre les
collectivités territorial et l'État cela
relève aussi de l'évidence je sais que
beaucoup d'entre vous sont quelque peu
polarisés par ces notions de bloc de
compétences que nous retrouverons
bientôt mais il n'y a pas une seule
politique publique qui ne soit
partenariale transversale et
contractuelle hier lorsque l'on
s'intéressait aux finances publiques de
l'État et des collectivités d'une
manière générale il y avait d'un côté la
composante état de l'autre la composante
collectivité territoriale puis la
troisième composante des organismes
sociaux aujourd'hui vous n'avez plus de
cloison étanche mes chers collègues élus
territoriaux le premier financier des
collectivités territoriales c'est l'état
pour différentes raisons et vous
participez aussi à des politiques
régalienne quand l'on prend l'origine
des ressources de la sécurité sociale 30
% de ces ressources proviennent de la
fiscalité et pour une majeure partie de
la CG donc la solidarité est une absolue
nécessité alors monsieur le ministre je
voudrais m'interroger très rapid
sur ce Pact de solidarité
entre l'État et les collectivités
territoriales tout spécialement dans sa
partie budgétaire financière et fiscale
car mes chers collègues il ne faut pas
que nous attendions le moment du débat
budgétaire pour évoquer ces points et je
reste convaincu que l'un des rôles
précisement du Haut Conseil des
Collectivités Territoriales serait de
tout au long de l'année de mener bien
ces négociations pour aboutir au Pact
qu'il est important d'avoir je pense
tout d'abord que nous savons qu'il y a
chaque année entre 10 et 12 milliards
d'économie à faire et ce matin monsieur
le Président j'ai vu quelle difficulté
nous avions à nous mettre d'accord sur 5
millions et il y a là et il y a là
matière à débat et à
responsabilité il faut que nous
discutions des normes il faut que nous
discutions des dotations de la
péréquation voilà un grand débat et puis
deuxème élément les investissements il
faut que nos collectivités territoriales
l'État a une visibilité le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre doit hâter la mise
en place d'une nouvelle configuration
bancaire avec la banque publi des
collectivités locales porté par la
Banque Postale et la caiss des Dépôts et
Consignation il doit également aider les
associations d'élus à définir leur
projet d'agence de financement des
collectivités locales et j'étais très
heureux comme vous tous j'en suis
persuadé d'entendre cet après-midi
Monsieur le Premier Ministre prendre fê
et causes tout comme hier monsieur le
Président lorsque la Caisse des Dépôts
et Consignation a annoncé son engagement
de 20 milliards pour des investissements
longs au bénéfice des collectivités
locales ceci crée de la visibilité et de
l'assurance alors qu'attendent les
collectivit locale tout d'abord il faut
que nous sachions quelle peut-être
l'enveloppe de prêt qui peut s'étendre
sur un mandat il faut aussi monsieur le
ministre que le gouvernement avec les
instances puisse veiller à l'évolution
des taux d'intérêt et que le
gouvernement ses instances soi également
un conseil moi je suis très heureux que
les taux directeurs de la Banque
centrale européenne est baissé en
octobre 2008 ils étaient de 3,75 15 % au
11 janvier 2012 ils sont à
0,75 % et le coût moyen pondéré des
crédits aux entreprises varie de 1,93 %
à
3,12 %. et lorsque l'on parle des
collectivités de leur rapport à l'état
il faut aussi que ces collectivité
puissent participer à certains débats
intéressant la politique de prê conduite
par certains organismes et à ce sujet je
voudrais dire deux mots monsieur le
ministre M chers collègues de la
situation du Crédit Immobilier de France
nous connaissons l'historique de ce
dossier mais monsieur le ministre je ne
pourrais pas imaginer que le trésor est
conditionné l'obtroit de sa garantie à
l'extinction pure et simple du Crédit
Immobilier de France supprimant ainsi
170000 logements d'ici à 77 arrêtant la
réalisation d'une convention signée avec
l'État engageant la construction de
25000 logements horizon 77
et ne s'intéressant pas aux 2500
personnes qui sont employées et monsieur
le Président de la République et nous
sommes à ses côtés a pris l'engagement
de livrer 500000 logements sociaux
intermédiaires et étudiants c'est un
objectif comment dirais-je exigeant ne
prenons pas de retard autre point dans
ce pacte entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales veillons à
conserver un minimum d'autonomie fiscale
et ne confondons pas autonomie fiscale
et autonomie financière et à ce point
monsieur le rapporteur général je
souhaite que vous soyez entendu que nous
soyons entendus et qu'il y ait une mise
en œuvre de la révision des valeurs
locatives professionnelles au 1er
janvier 2015 comme vous l'avez souhaité
monsieur le ministre je sais que vous
nous écoutez et je souhaite aussi comme
vous monsieur le rapporteur général qu'à
partir du 1er janvier 2016 il y ait une
révision expérimentale des valeurs
locatives des ménages tant que ceci ne
sera pas fait vous l'avez dit cet
après-midi la péréquation reposera sur
des des pipés je termine monsieur le
ministre par un point qui peut ne pas
avoir aujourd'hui un consensus total et
je sais que vous y réfléchissez mais
c'est un engagement du Président de la
République et cet engagement là il est
fondamental car il intéresse la justice
fiscale chers élus des département il
vous intéresse aussi cet engagement quel
est-il c'est le numéro 14 je le lit la
contribution de chacun sera rendue plus
équitable par une grande réforme Perm
ant la fusion à terme de l'impôt sur le
revenu et de la CG dans le cadre d'un
prélèvement simplifié sur le revenu PSR
une part de cet impôt sera affecté aux
organismes de sécurité sociale c'est une
réforme fondamentale qui allie la
progressivité et l'élargissement des
assiettes elle concerne directement la
compétitivité des entreprises dans
quelques temps vous allez nous parler de
la réforme de la taxe sur la valeur
ajoutée vous avez raison cette réforme
est totalement différente de celle que
le précédent gouvernement a fait mais
une fois que cette réforme intéressant
la TVA sera
actée nous serons obligés en
responsabilité de venir à ce point j'ai
évoqué les départements vous ne pourrez
pas chers collègues des département
allez chaque année négocier une
enveloppe auprès du gouvernement c'est
possible mais il faut aussi que les
engagements qui sont les vôtres en
matière de solidarité reposent sur un
grand impôt juste national et je ne
quitte pas l'impôt local vous le savez
bien monsieur le ministre je suis de
ceux qui ont toujours plaidé pour qu'une
partie au moins de la taxe d'habitation
soit assise sur les revenu nous y sommes
je note d'ailleurs qu'un consensus sur
ce point comme sur d'autres c'est
d'ailleurs réalisé lors de cette
merveilleuse aventure que nous avons
vécu tous ensemble ici avec les états
généraux de la démocratie territoriale
merci merci chers
collègues la parole est à Marie-Hélène
desgau madame le Président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mardi
dernier l'agence moudis dégradé la note
de la France d'un cran personne ne peut
s'en réjouir mais permettez-moi de
m'étonner que Madame la porte-parole du
gouvernement relayé en cela par d'autres
ministre a déclaré que cette décision
vient sanctionner la politique qui a été
conduite par le précédent gouvernement
et non je pense que Madame Valou
belcassem et ses collègues et vous-même
chers collègues n'ont pas bien regardé
ni le calendrier ni les explications
motivant la décision de l'agence de
lation et c'est bien dommage parce que
c'est la première fois que je vois une
explication une motivation aussi nette
aussi claire d'une agence de notation au
moment d'une dégradation d'une note
souveraine je rappelle que mudis a mis
notre pays sous surveillance négative à
la suite du projet de loi de finances de
juillet 2012 un des premiers textes qui
était défendu par par l'actuelle
majorité
moodis soulligne cette semaine un
problème structurel de compétitivité la
précédente majorité s'y était attaqué
mes chers collègues avec la TVA
compétitivité la réforme des universités
les investissements d'avenir les pôles
de compétitivité la réforme des
retraites et la baisse des dépenses
publiques or vous quand vous êtes
arrivés vous avez commencer par revenir
sur nombre de ces mesures souvent par
pure idéologie et surtout sur celle
d'une d'une TVA compétitivité alors mis
dénonce une trajectoire budgétaire 2013
2017 trop optimiste dont vous êtes
entièrement responsable puisque c'est
vous qui l'avez déterminé dans le projet
de loi de programmation des finances
publiques modi s'inquiète aussi d'un
niveau de taxes et de cotisation sociale
élevé évidemment votre budget 2013 en
plus de la loi de finance rectificative
de juillet 2 2012 ne peut qu'aviver ses
craintes au total au moins 30 milliards
d'impôts supplémentaires moodis dénonce
enfin un problème structurel de rigidité
du marché du travail les partenaires
sociaux négocient sur ces sujets c'est
totalement leur rôle et nous souhaitons
qu'ils puissent aboutir à un accord je
rappellerai simplement que nous avions
lancé les contrats compétitivité emploi
qui donne une certaine souplesse aux
entreprises en fonction des variations
de leur carnet de commande tout en
maintenant les salariés dans l'emploi
vous n'avez pas souhaité leur donner
suite mais ils ne sont pas forcément
totalement enterré par les partenaires
sociaux à outre moodis a déclaré
maintenir la France sous surveillance
négative il ne pourrait en être
autrement car les annonces du
gouvernement à la suite du rapport
Galois ne sont pas suffisamment
convainquante ou mériterait d'être
concrétisé au plus vite elles ne peuvent
attendre mes chers collègues 14 comme
cela a d'abord été annoncé il semble
maintenant qu'on revienne là-dessus et
que on veuille bien s'en saisir
peut-être plus rapidement attendons de
voir la seule conclusion collective
sérieuse raisonnable responsable que
nous pouvons tirer de la dégradation de
la de la note de notre pays et qu'il
faut engager rapidement les réformes
structurelles c'est-à-dire tant que la
dette souveraine française peut encore
bénéficier de taux d'intérêt bas le
temps donc des atternoimements touche à
sa fin monsieur le ministre et les
préconisations du rapport Galois qui qui
qui ne sont pas franchement nouvelles
mais qui sont pédagogiquement très
utiles sont là pour vous le rappeler
puissent-elles servir d'aiguillon et
vous aider à agir rapidement fussent au
prix de renoncement doctrinaux quand il
s'agit de l'avenir de notre pays c'est
pourquoi comme mes collègues du groupe
UMP je pense que le budget que vous nous
présentez n'est plus d'actualité il est
dépassé il est urgent que vous puissiez
le compléter des mesures que vous avez
annoncé pour la compétitivité ce serait
la meilleure leçon à retenir de la
décision de moudise au lieu de chercher
à rendre responsable vos prédécesseurs
il est un effet indispensable que la
représentation nationale et les
entreprises elles-mêmes puissent
connaître dans les plus brefs délais la
manière dont vous allez décliner les
dispositions envisagées en particulier
nous nous interr sur le recours à un
crédit d'impôt dont la formule de calcul
n'est toujours pas connue et dont la
montée en charge serait progressive sur
3 ans cela signifie qu'au total il n'y
aurait pas de baisse claire des charges
sociales et qu'il n'y aurait pas de choc
de compétitivité mais une très une très
légère secousse de 10 milliards d'euros
quand même l'an prochain vos
propositions franchement sont-elles à la
hauteur des enjeux à ce stade nous en
doutons mais nous espérons pouvoir avoir
ce débat très
prochainement je voudrais
maintenant terminer mon intervention à
abordant un autre sujet très sensible
pour certaines entreprises et pour les
collectivités locales il s'agit des
dispositions prévues à l'article 15 du
projet de loi de finances pour 2013 qui
vise notamment pour les grandes
entreprises à limiter la déductibilité
des charges financière essentiellement
constitué des intérêts d'empereur la
logique de ce dispositif et de pur
rendement pour les finances publiques et
d'une conception que l'on pourrait
qualifier de morale du financement des
entreprises réduire le financement par
endettement au profit du financement en
fond propre mais il faudra nous
expliquer comment les entreprises
françaises qui se caractérisent
malheureusement par des marges faibles
peuvent s'autofinancer nous nous
demandons d'ailleurs si les différentes
mesures de la loi de finance en matière
des ne financière ne vont pas finalement
mettre nos entreprises dans une impasse
pour financer leurs investissements à un
moment où la récession qui se profile au
niveau de la zone euro ne les encourage
pas à la prise de risque plus
particulièrement je voudrais insust sur
le fait que le dispositif d'article 15
déséquilibre complètement le financement
de la construction d'infrastructure pour
le compte de personnes publiques au
premers chef les collectivités locales
qui assurent je le rappelle 70 % de
l'investissement public même si c'est
pas ce chiffre- là sous la forme de de
contrat de partenariat mais c'est quand
même la première conséquence elle est
évidemment bien sûr de cette décision
que vous prenez dans ce budget de
réduire les bénéfices des entreprises
concernées au pire des cas ça pourrait
entraîner des défauts ensuite pour les
contrat à venir on peut s'attendre à une
augmentation des tarifs ou à une
réduction des travaux à la charge
entreprise portant le projet en tout tas
de cause une augmentation du coût global
pour le contractant public et
permettez-moi mes chers collègues de
dire qu'il y a quand même derrière ça
des financements énormes comme par
exemple des financements ferroviaires et
la partie tourbordeau par exemple hein
quant au contrat en cours et bien
l'équilibre de tout projet prenant en
compte la possibilité de la
déductibilité des intérêt sur toute la
durée d'un contrat de partenariat ben il
est évident que la mesure envisage met
en péril ces projets au-delà
d'éventuelles dispositions
contractuelles permettant une
augmentation de la rémunération
composant l'augmentation du coût du
crédit donc ce dispositif
entraînent donc tout à la fois un grave
déséquilibre économique micro-économique
je dirais au niveau des entreprises et
un déséquilibre macro-économique au
niveau des finances publiques locales et
nationales nous pouvons donc
raisonnablement anticiper qu'il
impliquera une dégradation des finances
publiques pour un gain fiscal quasi nul
dans ces conditions il est indispensable
de revenir sur les dispositions de
l'article 15 et à tout le moins pour les
PPP pour les partenariats publics privés
j'ai déposé mes chers collègues un
amendement en ce sens nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler enfin je
souhaiterais ajouter que encore une fois
une vision par trop idéologique
s'accorde mal avec la réalité économique
il ne faut pas rejeter par principe ce
recours par exemple au PPP comme sous
prétexte qui serait d'inspiration anglo
saxon ou je ne sais quoi comme je
l'entends dire ces derniers temps au
contraire il faut les considérer comme
un instrument d'investissement de long
terme avec partage des risques comme un
vrai contrat de partenariat pour une
meilleure qualité des infrastructure
publique et intégrant la maintenance et
l'entretien pour conclure monsieur
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
vous aurez compris que comme les autres
membres de mon groupe je ne voterai pas
le budget ce projet de budget tel qu'il
nous est présenté parce qu'il correspond
pas à la réalité il ne correspond pas ce
n'est pas à la traduction de la
politique que vous voulez mener ça ne
correspond pas puisque vous nous avez
parlé de mesures prises après ce contrat
à le rapport Gallois vous nous avez
parlé d'un certain nombre de choses qui
ne figurent pas dans ce projet de budget
donc ce n'est pas l'instrument financier
de votre politique il n'y a il n'y a pas
de sincè é et il n'y a pas de de de de
volonté politique traduite dans ce
document budgétaire comme ça devrait
être le cas pour conclure monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues vous aurez
compris donc je ne le voterai pas mais
surtout parce que d'abord il n'est plus
d'actualité par rapport aux dernières
annonce du gouvernement c'est donc un
document dépassé qui n'est pas une
prévision sincère ensuite parce que les
choix de politique économique qu'il
suppose notamment une augmentation
massive des impôts et une baisse
proportionnelle faible des dépenses
publiques ne constitue pas le chemin
approprié pour retrouver notre triple A
je vous
remerci merci chers
collègues la parole est à Richard
Jung madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
une fois de plus j'ai le privilège
d'être le dernier orateur et ça n'est
pas toujours chose
facile nous l'avons dit ce budget se
prépare dans un contexte économique
fortement dégradé cela a été dit mais ce
que je veux souligner c'est que cette
dégradation elle vient de
loin oui elle vient de loin ça n'est pas
2008 comme on voudrait nous le faire
croire c'est malheureusement
malheureusement pour notre pays et pour
notre économie quelque chose de beaucoup
plus profond je vous en donne trois
exemples et vous verrez
que ça n'est pas ce sont pas des
exemples sectaires contrairement à
beaucoup de choses que j'ai entendu ce
soir le la dégradation de la balance
commerciale depuis
2002 plus 3 milliards en 2002 vous
connaissez les chiffres pour
aujourd'hui plus grave encore la baisse
de la productivité horaire des salariés
français qui était une des plus fortes
du monde c'était un de nos points les
plus forts la productivité horaire de
nos travailleurs elle a commencé à
diminué à baissé
malheureusement et depuis non bien avant
ant monsieur de bien avant elle a
commencé au début de l'Euro voilà donc
tout le monde en a sa part et puis la
dette publique et ben la dette publique
on l'a dit doublement en disant c'est
difficile de faire mieux alors arrivé à
ce stade là je me suis
interrogé je me suis rappelé ce que nous
avait dit le président ce matin le
président
Marini il nous a dit bon ce sont des
jeux de rôle chacun critique vous vous
vous l'opposition vous critiquez le
projet de de de loi de finance et vous
la majorité vous le la défendrez nous
sommes chacun dans nos rôles ça donne
l'impression d'être un peu hein du
théâtre peu
sincère alors je me suis dit est-ce que
c'est la peine de redire tout ça mais
j'ai écouté les orateurs de la majorité
de l'ancienne majorité de l'ancienne
majorité et je dois dire et ce qui m'a
et ce qui me frappe c'est que je n'ai
pas vu que vous ayez pris la mesure de
ce que je viens de dire je n'ai entendu
que des leçons qui nous ont été donné
aucune critique aucune autocritique au
moins le maoisme avait cet avantage
c'est qu'on pratiquait l'autocritique et
ben peut-être faudrait-il oui une grande
démocratie peut-être faudrait-il en
prendre de la
graine je n'ai entendu que des que des
leçons de pratique budgétaire des
jugements critiques et des conseils et
ça m'a fait penser à une phrase de didro
dans les
entretiens c'est mieux que Mao he quand
même didro puis puis c'est français bon
voilà je ne sais ce que c'est que des
principes sinon des règles qu'on
prescrit aux autres voilà ce que j'ai
entendu ce soir et le fond est le
suivant vous avez voulu mener une
politique économique et budgétaire qui
après tout avait sa logique c'est pas la
mienne c'est pas la nôtre mais elle
avait sa logique elle est je m'excuse
madame desg elle est d'inspiration
anglo-saxonne ça consiste à baisser les
recettes la fiscalité la fiscalité des
entreprise en disant ça va permettre aux
entreprises d'investir et d'aller de
l'avant et puis de baisser la fiscalité
des ménages en disant ça va générer du
pouvoir d'achat et de l'épargne et là
aussi ça va aller vers l'investissement
bien vous avez fait ces baisses massives
de fiscalité vous n'avez d'ailleurs pas
fait les dépenses la baisse des dépenses
publiques correspondantes mais enfin et
le résultat et ben écoutez c'est c'est
il y a pas de miracle c'est que les
déficit se accru de façon exponentielle
mais c'est pas ça le plus grave le plus
grave c'est que ça n'a pas marché cette
politique là elle n'a pas marché et vous
devriez en prendre acte vous devriez
dire cette voie là bien elle est fermée
on l'a essayé malheureusement bon ben ça
n'a pas marché regardez l'emploi a
explosé la croissance économique s'est
arrêtée les exportations se sont
effondré l'innovation pareil bon donc on
en tire les conclusions mais c'est pas
ça que vous faites vous n'en tirez pas
les conclusions et du coup nous sommes
quand même fondés à nous demander quel
est votre doctrine économique vous qui
n'arrêtez pas de nous dire que nous n'en
avons pas et qui critiqua les
soi-disant les soi-disants engagements
idéologiques et idéologique c'est pas
bon hein dans votre bouche on sent que
c'est pas quelque chose de de
recommandable bon c'est oui c'est un peu
rouge c'est un peu rouge c'est un peu
Mao bon mais nous on se demande ce que
vous proposez moi j'ai pas entendu ce
soir à travers oui mais vous nous faites
la leçon alors vous nous faites la leçon
pour nous dire de faire quoi est-ce que
vous voulez est-ce que vous voulez
abolir les 35 heur oui ah bon ah benah
écoutez alors là on est content de
l'entendre parce que on a pas vu que
vous l'ayez fait vous avez vous avez eu
10 ans pour le faire et vous êtes bien
gardé de le faire
non c'est d'ailleurs vous qui les avez
inventé hein
bien les 35 he bon est-ce que vous
voulez rétablir le bouclier fiscal vous
l'avez dit vous l'avez dit vous voulez
le rétablir tel qu'il est ben oui il est
supprimé est-ce que vous voulez
refiscaliser les heures supplémentaires
vous le dites ça non mais il faut le
dire de façon cohérente il faut qu'on
sache quel est le programme économique
alternatif que vous proposez voilà donc
je je développe pas plus sur ce point
mais enfin il fallait que ça soit dit
quand même parce que hein il faut il
faut jouer à égalité en la matière bien
je reviens au budget à la stratégie
qu'il soutend qui est une stratégie
forte claire réaliste le premier point
c'est la responsabilité
budgétaire personne jusqu'à maintenant
dans la 5e République sous la 5e
République n'a proposé un budget aussi
ambitieux quant à la réduction des
déficits bah écoutez vous en connaissez
vous pouvez nous dire quel gouvernement
a pratiqué une réduction de déficit non
vous ne l'avez pas voilà nous devons
dire la vérité au français il faut
résoudre la crise de l'endettement et je
vous rappelle d'ailleurs que la France
est sous surveillance communautaire
depuis 2 ans sur le déficit c'est donc
pas quelque chose de tout à fait récent
donc cet engagement il il est de ramener
le déficit public à 3 % pour la fin 2013
et j'ose penser d'ailleurs que c'est un
objectif
que la majorité et l'opposition partage
bien nous avons proposé le gouvernement
propose 30 milliards de Mobilis de
mobilisation pour atteindre cet
objectif et la recette est simple état
ménag et entreprise participe chacun
pour un tiers à cette réduction du
déficit vous avez crié au loup et vous
avez crié au matraquage fiscal mais ENF
je vous rappelle quand même que les
gouvernements Fillon ont créé 45 taxes
nouvelle 45 c'est quand même pas
indifférent pour 16 milliards d'euros de
hausse d'impôt c'est-à-dire qu'en
réalité cette politique de baisse des
impôts que vous prétendiez suivre vous
ne l'avez même pas suivi celle-là mais
enfin bon on
pourra pourquoi ces 30 milliards et
pourquoi 10 milliards sur la la
réduction enfin la baisse des
dépenses cela été dit à plusieurs
reprises c'est parce que la hausse
d'impôt a un caractère moins récessif
qu'une baisse des dépenses et ceci a été
confirmé encore récemment par le FMI
vous avez d'ailleurs vous-même vous vous
l'avez fait en relançant la croissance
par la dépense avec le grand empreint on
voit bien que tout le monde ici est
kénésien mais certains sont des
kénésiens assumés d'autres sont des
kénésiens honteux voilà et à ces 10
milliards d'économie de dépenses il faut
rajouter les 2 milliards et demi
d'économie sur le budget sociale sur
l'économ le budget de la Sécurité
sociale nous sommes donc à 12 et demi
d'économie et j'ai entendu peut-être pas
ce soir mais j'ai entendu dans à
d'autres occasions que ce que vous
preniez c'était 15 milliards d'économie
les 30 divisé par 2 moitié sur les
dépenses moitié pour les recettes
franchement entre 12 et demi et 15 on
peut discuter hein mais je crois pas que
ça soit une
pour ne
pas pour ne pas voter pour ne pas voter
ce budget cet excellent budget
bien le deè le deè axe du budget je je
passer rapidement on l'a on a développé
les différentes mesures qui sont
proposées la la tranche à 45 le
plafonnement des niches et cetera ces
mesures
ont l' objectif en fait de
redistribution sociale important
c'est-à-dire c'est la dimension de la
justice dans ce dans ce budget et enfin
je veux souligner que ce budget a pour
vocation je l'ai dit de relancer la
croissance et la création
d'emploi c'est le cœur de la stratégie
de la demande qui est défendue par le
gouvernement comme la revalorisation du
SMIC et laallocation de rentrée scolaire
on ont été les premiers volets voilà
voilà mes chers collègues les
principales remarques que je voulais
faire sur ce PLF vous comprendrez bien
sûr que nous le
soutiendrons dans les amendements et
dans le vote final merci merci chers
collègues la parole est à monsieur le
ministre en charge du
budget
madame la la Présidente je vais
m'efforcer de répondre à l'opposition je
me permettra ensuite de répondre à la
majorité j'espère que chacun comprendra
cet ordre là les accusations ont été
plusieurs fois répété par exemple de
matraquage fiscal je crois que
l'expression a été dans la bouche de la
plupart des orateurs de
l'opposition la formule est
naturellement forte il faut peut-être y
regarder de plus près je m'étais déjà
exprimé dans mon intervention liminire
pour rappeler ce qu'il en avait été des
mesures déjà prises par le dernier
gouvernement Fillon voté par la majorité
parlementaire qui le soutenait à
l'époque par les parlementaires au moins
de l'UMP au Sénat des mesures qui
avaient abouti à augmenter les
prélèvements de 30 milliards d'euros je
voudrais rappeler qu'entre 2007 et 2012
la promesse avait été faite de baisser
les préléements obligatoires de 80
milliards d'euros et cô total ils ont
augmenté d'un point et demi de PIB
c'est-à-dire de 30 milliards d'euros
précisément ce que la précédente
majorité a dû se résoudre à décider
devant ce que je me suis permis
d'appeler l'équation impossible entre la
baisse des recettes décidé en début de
mandature et l'augmentation de la
dépense publique puisque cette baisse
des recettes notamment de l'État ne
s'est pas accompagné une baisse de la
dépense publique en point de PIB quand
l'UMP est arrivé aux affaires du pays en
2002 la dépense publique était d'un peu
moins de 52 % du PIB quand l'UMP a été
désavoué dans les urnes par nos
concitoyens la dépense publique était de
56 % du PIB 4 points de PIB en 10 ans
donc une augmentation de la dépense
publique avec comme seul échappe par toi
possible l'endettement dès lors que les
recettes baissent et que la dépense
publique ne baisse pas du concurrence
loin sans faut mais augmente il faut
s'endetter les 900 milliards d'euros
d'endettement
entre 2000 2002 et 2012 trouve une
grande partie de leur explication dans
cet effet de ciseau entre des baisses
d'impôts voulu pour des raisons
politiques et des baisses de dépenses
évité pour des raisons également
politiques mais reconnaissons-le moins
bien assumé ni à l'époque ni maintenant
par ceux qui en furent les responsables
accusation aussi Serge d'assau l'a fait
emerine montescou également alberri de
montolfier Jean artui sénateur du Loir
président Larcher de filer la dépense je
pense que cette accusation ne résiste
pas à l'analyse d'abord parce que cette
année le déficit sera bien de 4,5 % le
déficit public sera bien de 4,5 % et
s'il sera de 4,5 % c'est bien sûr parce
qu'il a fallu la cours des compte
n'avait pas laissé d'autres possibilités
à envisager il a bien fallu en loi de
finance rectificative augmenter des
recettes qui manquaient mais il a fallu
aussi maîtriser la dépense et sans la
maîtrise de cette dépense jamais la
France n'aurait pu garantir le respect
de sa parole c'est-à-dire un déficit de
4,5 % en cette fin d'année 2012 mieux on
le verra je crois en loi de finance
rectificative non seulement la dépense a
été tenue mais elle a été si je ve dire
inférieure à ce que les certains augures
dans l'opposition pouvaient annoncer
puisque par rapport à la loi de finances
initiale l'exécution budgétaire montrera
une économie une économie de 3,6
milliards d'euros ce chiffre est déjà en
lui-même évocateur mais je voudrais en
donner un autre qui fera l'objet de
document budgétaire que naturellement
les sénateurs auront tout loisir
d'examiner lorsque ce texte leur sera
soumis pour être délibéré je l'espère
voter lorsque l'on examine donc ce qu'il
en est de la
dépense de loi de finan exécuté à loi de
finance exécuté on s'aperçoit que ces 5
dernières années quand on compare
d'exécution à exécution l'augmentation
de la dépense ça a été de 6 milliards
d'euros en moyenne d'une année sur
l'autre entre 2007 et 2012 mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sous l'empire de
la précédente majorité non seulement la
dépense publique n'a pas été maîtrisée
mais elle a augmenté puisque nous avons
constaté une aggravation du déficit
d'exécution et exécution de 6 milliards
d'euros nous constaterons cette fin
d'année 2012 une diminution de 200
millions d'euros d'exécution à exécution
le chiffre est relativement faible si
l'on se contente de le citer mais si
l'on compare à ce que fut l'évolution au
préalable 6 milliards à ces moins de 100
millions d'euros alors on voit bien que
contrairement aux affirmation indiquée
qui relève peut-être davantage du réflex
de la réflexion ce gouvernement avec la
p sa majorité maîtrise parfaitement la
dépense publique j'ajoute que là encore
les chiffres sont connus entre 2002 et
2007 l'évolution de la dépense publique
a été chaque année et en moyenne de 2,3
% entre 2007 et 2012 l'évolution de la
dépense publique en moyenne et chaque
année d'une année sur l'autre a été de
1,7 % nous nous sommes engagés dans une
loi de programmation pluriannuelle à ce
que cette évolution soit de 0,7 % et en
fait l'année prochaine elle le sera
probablement moins et en moyenne car des
économies supplémentaires ont été
programmé quoi qu'il en soit 2,3 1,7 07
la tendance est incontestablement là il
ne nous semble pas que nous inscrivons
dans cette tendance et faisons beaucoup
mieux que nos prédécesseurs
cette politique mérite les critiques que
je viens d'indiquer à savoir une
accusation que je crois factuellement
inexacte de laisser filer la dépense
publique il est indiqué également je
crois que l'accusation a été reprise par
vous monsieur de lâre que la Cour des
comptes préconisait une réduction plus
forte de la dépense la lecture des
rapports de la Cour des Comptes est
effectivement une source d'inspiration
très vive je peux en témoigner lorsque
j'étais parlementaire de l'opposition
lorsqu'il s'agit de critiquer le
gouvernement mais il se trouve que en
l'espèce la Cour des comptes ne dit pas
cela elle préconise un ajustement à
minima équilibré en de dépenser recettes
c'est ce que nous nous efforceront de
faire tout au long de la mandature avec
un partage équilibré moitié moitié tout
en reconnaissant si l'on cite les
rapports de la Cour des compte ne
mettons pas peut-être la totalité de ces
recommandations tout en reconnaissant
que compte tenu de la situation des
finances publiques dont nous héritons le
gouvernement ne pourra pas faire
autrement qu'augmenter significativement
les impôts et que demeurant le précédent
gouvernement Fillon il y avait largement
procéder sans me semble-t-il que les
parlementaires qui le soutenaient à
l'époque ne manifestent la moindre
émotion beaucoup d'entre vous ont
également critiquer l'hypothèse de
croissance juget irréaliste là encore
c'est un grand classique du débat
budgétaire que d'estimer que le
gouvernement propose au Parlement une
évolution de la croissance économique
irréaliste tout exagérément optimiste
nous maintenons cette prévision à 0,8 %
nous le maintenons parce que les
prévisions qui sont indiquées via ce
qu'on appelle le consensus ces
prévisions là ne sont qu'une moyenne
entre certains qui envisagent une
récession à - 06 d'autres qui envisagent
une progression de la croissance à 0,9
je pense en particulier à Madame
Mathilde Lemoine qui est chef économiste
HSBC la moyenne est évidemment nettement
inférieure au 0,8 que nous annonçons
mais nous estimons que le 08 reste
quelque chose de raisonnable j'en veux
pour preuve au demeurant le chiffre
récemment connu du 3e trimestre histoire
tranchera et les uns et les autres
auront à rendre compte soit de leurs
prévisions soit de leur critique même
s'il est vrai mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que si la croissance ne repart
pas en Europe elle ne repartira pas
davantage en France que nous sommes en
partie tributaire de la résolution de la
crise de la zone euro une crise que
manifestement les précédents dirigeants
de ce pays comme les dirigeants de nos
partenaires au sein de cette zone nont
manifestement pas réussi à trouver les
solutions nous espérons il par venir
avec la relance via la Banque européenne
d'investissement 240 milliards d'euros
d'investissement avec la décision de la
Banque centrale européenne on sait que
la France et l'Allemagne ont beaucoup
pesé en réalité en ce sens avec le
programme OMT avec la validation par la
Cour constitutionnelle de Carles rou des
mécanismes européens de solidarité avec
la décision précisément via ce mécanisme
européen de solidarité de refinancer les
banques en particulier espagnoles qui en
ont bien besoin bref avec un ensemble de
politiques européennes la mobilisation
de fonds structurels qui n'était pas
encore on se demande pourquoi d'ailleurs
bref avec toutes ces politiques
nouvelles instaurées depuis quelques
mois dont le mérite ne revient pas
exclusivement à la France mais dont le
revient le mérite revient en partie à la
France et à l'action très volontariste
du président de la République nous
espérons effectivement que cette
croissance repartira en Europe et que la
France en tirera naturellement le plus
grand profit il demeure que l'année
prochaine c'est un effort structurel de
deux points de PIB qui s'aê à être fait
et je ne crois pas qu'il ait dans notre
histoire contemporaine
d'exemple d'efforts structurelles aussi
important demander à notre pays j'ai
entendu certains parlementaires de
l'opposition indiqué qu'il partageait
l'objectif du gouvernement et de sa
majorité de respecter la parole de la
France et d'un déficite public à 3 %
l'effort structurel de 3 % il contribue
évidemment je connais la critique celle
de président Larché celle d'emerie de
montescou celle bien sûr de Monsieur
dead de Monsieur de luuard de Monsieur
de monolfier estimant qu'en 2013 il y
avait trop de prélèvement et pas assez
d'économie il y a autant de prélèvements
que ceux effectués par le précédent
gouvernement de Monsieur Fillon il y a
davantage d'économie que ce précédent
gouvernement avec votre soutien mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs avec davantage
d'économie que ce gouvernement n'en
avait proposé et la différence il en est
une et que nous commençons la mandature
comme cela quand vous l'avez fini ainsi
après l'avoir commencé en dépensant
beaucoup plus que vous n'auriez dû
dépenser puis- je vous rappeler que pour
la première année pleine de la
précédente ature c'est une augmentation
de la dépense publique de 11 milliards
d'euros que vous avez voté je crois me
souvenir avec un grand enthousiasme et
une vraie allégresse quand avec un sens
des responsabilités qu'on finira par
reconnaître ce gouvernement demande à sa
majorité une loi de finance initiale
d'accepter une loi de finance initiale
en 2013 qui respecte l'évolution de zéro
valeur dans le champ du Zéro valeur et
qui toute dépense de l'État confondu
connaîtra une augmentation de 03 % à
comparé au 3,3 % de 2008 nous faisons 10
fois mieux que vous en première année
pleine de mandature je comprends vos
critiques permettez-moi de vous rappeler
ce que vous avez pu faire le reproche
fut vif pour la compétitivité des
entreprises jugé insuffisante on peut
être d'accord sur le constat il est
connu l'année dernière le déficit du
commerce extérieur qui est quand même un
des témoins les plus aboutis du manque
de compétitivité de nos entreprises
l'année dernière c'est-à-dire sous
l'empire de votre majorité mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs de l'UMP le
déficit du commerce extérieur fut de
plus de 70 milliards d'euros nous
n'avions jamais connu un tel déficit du
commerce extérieur et puis je vous
rappelle qu'en 2001 ce commerce
extérieur était excédentaire 10 ans 10
ans de politique ayant abouti à un
déficit du commerce extérieur de 70
milliards d'euros je comprends que cela
inquiète mais cela ne qualifie peut-être
pas en tout cas dans les mois qui
suivent une alternance à donner des
leçons aussi catégorique et définitive
que celle que vous semblez donner à un
gouvernement qui lui n'attend pas la fin
de la mandature qui lui a été confiée
pour prendre des mesures quand vous avez
attendu précisément la fin de celle au
cours de laquelle vous étiez majoritaire
pour proposer un plan à 13 milliards
d'euros car j'ai vous ai bien entendu
monsieur de lâre indiquer que le plan
que nous proposions était une mesurette
à 20 mais je ne vous ai pas entendu
indiquer quand vous avez voté le plan à
13 milliards d'euros qu'il s'agissait
d'une mesure insuffisante donc si 13
étit suffisant il me semble que 20
devraiit y pourvoir et en tout cas nous
avons clairement une différence
d'analyse sur la politique économique à
mener en 2013 nous souhaitons préserver
la consommation des ménages et donc nous
ne regrettons pas d'avoir demandé au
Parlement qui nous a suivi de revenir
sur l'augmentation de la TVA pour 2013
si en revanche et en 2014 la modulation
des taux de TVA servira évidemment à
financer cette augmentation de la
compétitivité via la diminution du coût
du travail dans les entreprises mais la
différence et je crois qu'elle est
majeure avec le projet qui fut imaginé
connaissons-le dans une certaine
précipitation à la fin de la mandature
Sarkozy nous envisageons nous de
financer cette amélioration de la
compétitivité avec une baisse de la
dépense publique de 10 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires nous serons contraints
de procéder à cette bate de la dépense
publique de 10 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires via les économies
supposant des réformes structurelles que
nous nous engagerons quand d'autres se
sont contentés d'en parler en dehors de
la réforme des retraites nous le ferons
nous ce qui aura un double je vous rends
hommage une certaine une manière
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances un peisoire alors la
formule exacte de Monsieur Taleran est
tout ce qui est excessif est de peu
d'importance ce qui relativise votre
intervention je me permets de vous la
citer je le crois de la façon la plus
littérale qui soit mais non je ne crois
pas être excessif en indiquant que les
réformes de structure menées ces 10
dernières années en dehors de celles des
retraites n'ont pas été suffisamment
convaincantes ou en tout cas n'ont pas
produit les effets vous en espériez si
j'en juge par l'endettement qui a
progressé si j'en juge par le chômage
qui a progressé si j'en juge par le
déficit du commerce extérieur qui a
progressé et si j'en juge par ce qu'est
la part de l'industrie dans la valeur
ajoutée dans le produit intérieur brut
de notre pays quand vous êtes arrivé aux
affaires et majoritaires la part de
l'industrie était 17,3 % de la richesse
produite et quand les Français vous ont
retiré votre la confiance qu'il vous
avaient accordé cette part de
l'industrie dans le PIB était de
12,9 %. ça c'est le résultat de votre
politique et ça n'est pas la conséquence
des décisions prises ces 5 derniers mois
je me permets de vous le rappeler car si
je vois bien si je vois bien que pour
des raisons politiques vous essayez de
faire assumer par ce gouvernement en
place depuis 5 mois le bilan de 10 ans
d'action qui fut la vôre permettez au
ministrees du budget qui s'exprime
devant vous de rappeler ce qu'est le
constat au bout des 10 ans de majorité
qui vous ont vu gouverner ce pays pour
indiquer que ça n'est pas les 5 mois du
gouvernement de Jean-Marc hot qui a des
comptes à rendre au pays sur le bilan
objectivement très mauvais des
politiques économiques men C 10
dernières
annéesanné je parle de l'année 2013
autant qu'on la critique et je me
permets monsieur le président de la
commission des finances de renvoyer à
leur responsabilité ce qui semble donner
l'impression en parlant de 2013
d'accuser l'actuel gouvernement de la
situation économique du pays lors même
que nous savons vous et moi que tel
n'est pas le cas quant à la sincérité
dénoncé l'absence de sincérité pardon
dénoncé et par le président Marini et
par le le sénateur partui cette
sincérité je me répète l'histoire jugera
et pour le taux de croissance et pour
l'évolution des politiques économique
quant au crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité pour l'emploi j'ai bien
compris que certains se réjouissaient
que le cas échéant ces dispositions
soient examiné dans une loi de finance
rectificative j'ai cru comprendre aussi
que certains souhaitaent que dès lors
que la dépense serait exposée les
recettes le soitent aussi j'ignore ce
qu'il en sera mais convenons en même
temps que nous savons les uns et les
autres que si dépenses il doit y avoir
et il y aura dépenses ces dépenses ne
s'imputeront qu'à compter du 1er janvier
2014 et non pas de l'année 2013 et donc
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances comme je retiens beaucoup
euh vos critiques car je laiss de
qualité vous souhaitez que nous parlions
de l'année 2013 je ne parlerai donc pas
de l'année 2014 et donc pas davantage
des recettes nécessaires cette année-là
vous voyez que je sais vous entendre
quand vous me émettez des critiques que
je crois fonder sur la partie fiscale
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de m'exprimer
nous maintenons l'estimation qui est la
nôtre c'est-à-dire que 90 %
pardonnez-moi de l'effort supplémentaire
sera assumé par 10 % des ménages ce
chiffre je crois et judicieux et
contrairement à l'action que nos
prédécesseurs ont pu mener et au moment
où nous demandons un effort au pays nous
le jugeons pas bon nous de diminuer de 2
milliards d'euros les recettes de
l'impôt sur la fortune il me semble que
cette mesure était une mauvaise mesure
en terme de politique budgétaire et pas
davantage une bonne mesure dès lors que
l'on souhaite demander un effort au pays
elle fut équilibrée monsieur le
Président par une augmentation de 1,1 à
2,5 % de ce qu'on appelle les droits de
partage et il me semble qu'affirmer
comme vous l'avez fait je crois très
souvent que la réforme de l'ISF serait
financée par ceuxl même qui bénéficiit
de l'ISF trouve quelques limite quand je
rappelle la manière dont vous avez
financé cette réforme puisque je crois
pouvoir vous indiquer que les droits de
partage sont acquittés par celles et
ceux qui sortent d'une indivision celles
et ceux qui connaissent les preuves d'un
divorce et qu'il est je crois aventureux
d'affirmer que sortir d'une indivision
ou divorcer est le privilège des médages
qui seul payer l'ISF nous savons bien
que les classes moyennes ont payé cette
réforme deisf d'abord par l'augmentation
des droits de partage et ensuite parce
que le solde fut en partie financée par
l'endettement et que l'endettement est
ensuite remboursé par l'ensemble des
impôts acquités par l'ensemble des
Français je voudrais remercier les
parlementaires pardonnez-moi laisser
tomber mes notes remercier les
parlementaires de la majorité
gouvernementale pour leurs propos merci
au rapporteur général François Marc
d'abord pour le travail qu'il a fait en
commission bien sûr pour le soutien au
travail en faveur du redressement des
comptes dans la justice merci à lui
d'avoir souligné l'efficacité des choix
de répartition entre les dépenses et les
recettes et je souscris à l'analyse qui
fut FA fait et qui veut que sur le court
terme sur le court terme la hausse de la
fiscalité qui évidemment a des
conséquences récessives sur la
croissance c'est que ces hausses de
recettes fiscales ont un effet récessif
moindre que la baisse de la dépense
publique si en revanche sur le moyen et
le long terme il est probable que la
réduction de la dépense a un effet moins
récessif que la hausse des impôts cet
aspect des choses ne nous a pas échappé
ou FMI non plus merci d'avoir cité ces
études c'est la raison pour laquelle à
partir de l'année 2014 pardon de dans
jambé l'année 2013 mais à partir de
l'année 2014 ce sont pour l'essentiel
les économies dans la dépense qui
contribueront à l'équilibre des finances
publiques pour ensuite n'avoir que ce
moyen-là pour ajuster nos finances pour
en fin de mandature arriver à ce que
nous avons toujours prétendu vouloir
faire et que nous ferons un effort de
100 milliards d'euros se partageant pour
moitié entre un effort de la fiscalité
le gouvernement Fillon y a contribué car
dans les 50 milliards d'euros de
fiscalité il y a les mesures Fillon bien
entendu et puis une économie dans la
dépense et ça pour l'essentiel c'est le
gouvernement de Jean-Marc hraud qui y
pourvoira merci au rapporteur général de
l'avoir souligné avec beaucoup de force
merci au sénateur ENM d'avoir rappelé
l'importance du rôle des collectivités
territoriales avec la force et la fougue
qu'on lui connaît rappeler le changement
de méthole fondamental avec la
concertation comme moyen unique dans le
cadre de la discussion du PACT de
confiance et solidarité merci pour ces
propos très volontaires qui souhait voir
les compétences clarifi merci pour vos
encouragements à travailler pour la
péréquation ce projet de budget je crois
donne des signes assez forts en matière
de péréquation qu'il s'agit de la
péréquation verticale ou qu'il s'agisse
de la péréquation horizontale 360
milliards d'euros pour le bloc communal
50 pour les régions une vingtaine pour
pardon une trentaine pour les
départements une vingtaine pour les
régions bien sûr millions pardonnez-moi
si j'ai 10 milliards je vous pris de
m'en excuser mais vous aviez rectifié de
vous-même vous en remercie merci
également d'avoir indiqué la nécessité
du travail sur les normes avec des
intentions qui d'ailleurs ont toujours
été sincères et et transpartisanes moi
j'ai le souvenir du président de la
République qui précédent qui à l'issue
de la conférence sur les finances
publiques le président Marini s'en
souvient avait indiqué un moratoire sur
les normes devant s'imposé aux
collectivités locales j'ai également le
souvenir quelques mois plus tard du
sénateur Lambert votre ancien collègue
président de la commission consultative
sur l'évaluation des normes et indiquant
que depuis l'annonce ce moratoire jamais
sa commission n'avait eu examiner autant
de normes donc il y a parfois loin de la
coupe aux lèvres et si les intentions
sont les mêmes nous essaierons nous
d'avoir des résultats peut-être
davantage en cohérence avec des propos
dont je ne conteste la sincérité ni chez
les uns ni chez les autres merci au
président Collin au sénateur Fortassin
qui ont peut-être regretté que ce projet
de loi n'inscrivent pas la fusion de
l'impôt sur le revenu de la CSG je
voudrais indiquer à cela que cette
fusion est est une opération extrêmement
délicate ne pouvons se faire que par
étape il en existe au moins trois
d'abord l'harmonisation de l'assiette
ensuite la fixation du taux et enfin
définir l'organisme qui collecterait cet
impôt enfin unifié l'harmonisation de
l'assiette me semble être en bonne voie
dès lors que nous estimons pouvoir
soumettre les revenus du capital au même
barê euh de l'impôt sur le revenu que
les revenus du travail cette
harmonisation d'assiette est en cours
mais ce sera un travail de très longue
haleine auquel loit fininance après loit
finance il faudra probablement s'atteler
ce travail commence me semble-t-il avec
la réforme fiscale d'ampleur qui vous
est proposé dans ce projet de loi de
finances le président Collin a souligné
l'importance de lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale vous le savez car la chose est
maintenant connue puisque ce projet de
loi de finance rectificative a été
présenté en Conseil des ministres cette
loi de finance proposera au Parlement un
certain nombre de disposition je crois
très forte pour doter des moyens
juridiques qui lui manquent aujourd'hui
qui manquent aujourd'hui à
l'administration fiscale pour établir je
crois plus solidement telle résidence
nationale lors même que la prétention
est affirmée que la résidence est en
dehors de nos frontières je crois qu'un
certain nombre de dispositifs comme la
règle du double monsieur le le Président
vous connaissez qui fait que
l'administration fiscale ne peut
demander l'origine des fonds déposés sur
tel compte dès lors que ces fonds
n'excèdent pas du double les revenus
déclarés un certain nombre de règles
pouront je crois juridiquement faciliter
les travaux de l'administration des
finances publiques afin que dans
l'effort général qui est demandé à nos
concitoyens certains ne s'exonè pas non
seulement de manière illégale mais de
manière parfaitement choquante dans cet
effort national qui est demandé d'une
contribution légitime donc oui nous
allons tenter d'améliorer les choses
merci à Monsieur placé qui a semble-t-il
approuvé des décisions courageuses merci
à Monsieur gatolin d'avoir souligné
l'effort considérable de rédution de la
dette en préservant la justice sociale
tous ont regretté peut-être que ce
budget ne marque pas de transition vers
une fiscalité écologique à cela comme en
loit finan ctificative j'expliquerai que
les conséquences de la conférence
environnementale devront être re tiré
mais qu'elles ne peuvent l'être en
quelques semaines mes remerciements on
également peut-être tout
particulièrement au président repsamen
qui a rappelé que ce budget est un
budget de gauche je le cite comme
rarement un budget a pu l'être j'imagine
quelques approbations ici peut-être
quelques regrets ailleurs monsieur
Fortassin oui mais ce gouvernement
s'inscrit dans une logique politique qui
manifestement n'est pas celle que vous
vouliez prévoir monsieur le le sénateur
le peuple a parlé pour au moins 5 ans je
pense qu'il va falloir accepter cette
orientation qui n'est pas exactement
conforme à M vœux à vos vœux au moins
pendant ce temps-là merci encore au
sénateur fort à 5 a su remettre en
perspective le projet de budget en
rappelant la situation dont nous
héritons car nous devrons rappeler la
situation dont nous héritons chaque fois
que le sentiment sera fort chez les
parlementaires de la majorité que la
situation nous en sommes comptables lors
même que nous n'étions pas aux affaires
de depuis disant merci à Michel André
qui a rappelé pour sa part que la dette
était un impôt à la naissance qu'il nous
fallait proscrire qui indique toute la
volonté résolue de la majorité
gouvernementale à soutenir le
gouvernement dans son désir dans sa
volonté de désendetter notre pays merci
également Michel Andr l'a rappelé
d'avoir souligné l'effort pour l'emploi
pour l'éducation pour la jeunesse il est
vrai que l'éducation nationale se voir
restaurer au moins en partie dans ses
moyens à effectif constant pour la
fonction publique je rappelle qu'au-delà
des créations j'en ai indiqué le chiffre
tout à l'heure à la tribune auelà des
créations de postes dans l'Éducation
nationale 101 dans la police 480 dans la
justice 520 au-delà de ces créations de
postes il y a globalement un effort de
l'État puisque l'année prochaine ce sont
2317 postes qui seront supprimés dans
l'administration d'État donc nous tenons
bien la feuille de route qui a été
indiqué qui qui consiste à privilégier
certaines missions en demandant à
d'autres qui ne sont pas prioritaires
des efforts en particulier en terme de
moyens humains ça n'a rien à voir avec
la révision générale des politiques
publiques c'est-à-dire avec une
diminution des postes toutes
administrations publiques confondu et ce
quels que soient les choix politiques
menés par les uns et par les autres
merci également à George patient d'avoir
souligné que les moyens de l'outreem
sont préservés merci à
jean-germain d'avoir souligné
l'importance de l'allègement des N je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure pour contribuer
à la maîtrise de la dépense des
collectivités territoriales il s'agit
bien d'un deschantiers importants que le
gouvernement engage dans le cadre du PCT
de compétitivité et d'ailleurs un groupe
de travail éit mis en place à cette fin
merci enfin à Michel Berson qui a
souligné l'amélioration du crédit impôt
recherche qui est maintenu dans ce qu'au
fond le Parlement avait décidé de faire
je crois de manière assez consensuelle
et qui est majoré pour les PME de 300
millions d'euros dans ce projet de
budget c'est une des rares lignes
budgétaires qui progressent et qui qui
n'est pas diminué ça montre bien le
souci qu'a le gouvernement de la
vitalité des entreprises et en
particulier de la recherche et de
l'innovation car c'est par la recherche
l'innovation et l'investissement
qu'évidemment la situation pourra
commencer à s'améliorer ce chiffre a été
cité par le sénateur Berson je l'en
remercie je le reprends évidemment merci
aussi à lui d'avoir indiqué la
sécurisation du dispositif puisque par
voie de rcrit nous assurons une plus
grande visibilité aux entreprises il ne
s'agit pas pour celle-là d'avoir le
sentiment que ce que les uns promettent
d'autres ne le tiennent pas dans une
forme de déloyauté qui serait non
seulement très mauvais à loi mais
également très préjudiciable au climat
économique et à la vie des entreprises
voilà mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
peut-être ai-je oublié de répondre à
d'autres oui j'ai oublié de répondre à
Richard Jung qui m'en excuse il a
rappelé les termes de l'équation
impossible je le remercie et il a
également rappelé que cette politique
celle qui a été en vigueur pendant 10
ans a échoué j'ai indiqué les éléments
les paramètres économiques qui prouvent
que cette politique a échoué oui mais
j'ai eu le sentiment monsieur le
Président qu'en écoutant les
parlementaires de l'opposition parfois
certaines choses étaient également
redites alors j'essaie de le redire en
m'efforçant peut-être de le redire moins
que cela ne fut dit je m'efforce sous
votre grande vigilance d'être peut-être
un peu en dessous mais n'ai pas eu le
sentiment que la répétition était
absente des propos des parlementaires de
l'opposition si si vous avez le
sentiment que tous tenent des propos
originaux les un par rapport aux autres
alors je vous prie d'écuser par avance
le jugement peut-être un peu sommaire
que je
sembleé qui pourant si si j'ai répondu à
Monsieur dassasso bien sûr je viens de
répondre à Monsieur dasso j'ai bien pris
garde à ne pas omettre le sénateur
dassasso et enfin je vis répondre à
marie-elèine desego à qui je n'ai pas
répondu j'ai noté vos préoccupations
relatives à l'équilibre financier des
contrats de partenariat et à l'impact
potentiel sur financement de
l'investissement des collectivités le
gouvernement est ouvert lors de l'examen
de cette question et les aménagements
qui pourrai être né nire s'ils sont
conformes aux orientations des finances
publiques et aux politiques à l'égard
des collectivités locales que le
gouvernement souhaite mettre en œuvre
s'ils sont conformes le gouvernement
sera évidemment très ouvert j'espère
pouvoir compter dès lors que nous
veillerions à ce que vos satisfactions à
ce que vous ayez satisfaction sur ces
questions là j'espère que nous pourrons
alors compter contrairement à ce que
vous nous avez indiqué sur votre vote à
l'occasion de l'examen ce projet de loi
de finances initial je n'ai plus de note
j'espère ne pas avoir oublié de
parlementaire je m'en voudrais si si tel
est le cas si tel est le cas nous aurons
l'occasion de débattre lors de l'examen
des articles comment répondre à des
membres de la majorité de gauche du
Sénat mais qui ne sont pas membres de la
majorité gouvernementale si je l'ai bien
compris à l'occasion de quelques examen
de loi de finan ou de financement sauf
que notre analyse de la situation
économique n'est peut-être pas la même
nous estimons demander un effort déjà
extrêmement conséquent au pays aller
au-delà comme peut-être vous sembl le
suggérer ne serait pas nécessaire nous
avons besoin certes du travail tombons
d'accord là-dessus nous avons aussi
besoin du capital si l'on veut que la
croissance soit là nous sollicitons le
capital le solliciter au-delà de ce que
nous faisons et que vous semblez nous
suggérer nous paraîtrait
contre-productif nous avons une
divergence d'analyse sur ce sujet madame
la signatrice vous le savez de la même
manière que nous avons une divergence
d'analyse sur le rôle que l'Europe doit
jouer et sur le rôle que la France doit
jouer en Europe cette divergence est
très ancienne elle est très Histor elle
est tout à fait historique je doute je
doute que nous parvenions vous et moi et
quelle que soit la sincérité de nos
échanges je doute que nous parvenions à
la résorber en tout cas en totalité à
l'occasion de ces débats ces choix-là
nous amènent à prendre des décisions de
nature différentes nous estimons qu'il
faut faciliter l'investissement pour
permettre la croissance et l'emploi nous
estimons que l'Europe a un rôle à jouer
majeur à cet égard nous avons donc des
choix différents et à l'égard des
entreprises et peut-être à l'égard de
l'Europe ces choix différents qui sont
d'ailleurs respectables et le vôtre et
ceux du gouvernement ces choix-là
amènent à des conclusions différentes
qui aboutiront je le crains à ce que
vous n'approuviez peut-être pas
l'ensemble des dispositions que le
gouvernement s'apprête à soumettre à la
Haute Assemblée à l'occasion de l'examen
de ce projet de loi de finance je forme
simplement le vœu même la sénatrice que
lors du vote final vous permettiez
d'abord à la haute assemblée de
poursuivre l'examen de cette loi de
finance et qu'ensuite lors de cet acte
majeur qui est l'adoption d'un budget
vous par vos votes manifestiez non
seulement votre appartenance à une
majorité de gauche au Sénat tel est le
cas mais également votre appartenance
peut-être à la majorité gouvernementale
c'est en tout cas dans cet espoir que
j'aurai l'occasion de débattre avec vous
voilà merci madame la Présidente de
m'avoir laissé le temps de répondre je
l'espère de façon satisfaisante en tout
cas sincère à l'ensemble des
parlementaires et maintenant mesdames et
messieurs je vous donne rendez-vous à
l'occasion des articles et de l'examen
des amendements
merci merci Monsieur le Ministre la
discussion générale est
close voilà pour l'adoption définitive
de la règle d'or prévu par l'article 3
du traité budgétaire européen une orille
qui oblige la France à réduire son
déficit structurel à 0,5 % de son PIB
les sénateurs ont également ensuite
poursuivi avec l'examen du projet de loi
de finances 2013 aujourd'hui ils doivent
entamer la discussion du volet recette
très bonne matinée à tous sur Public
Sénat